Warum bringt man eine Mannschaft, die so funktioniert hat in dieser Situation, dass man sagt, man muss sie auf den Gegner anpassen? 2008 angepasst. Gegen Spanien im Finale verloren, gewachsenes Gebild der Spanier, man wusste wie die spielen. Die haben uns angepasst, sind raus. 2010, Südafrika, angepasst an die Spanier, rausgeflogen. 2012, angepasst an die Italiener, rausgeflogen. Achtung, und jetzt kommt der Clou. 2014, ab dem Viertelfinale, hat Jogi Löw jede Idee seiner Trainer, seines Stabs ignoriert und hat der Mannschaft vertraut. Und sie haben dreimal mit der gleichen Mannschaft ab Viertelfinale gespielt. So gewinnt man Titel.
Ja, so gewinnt man Titel. Ich begrüße euch zum Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost und was wir gerade hier im Intro gehört haben, das war vielleicht der Aufreger in Sachen Taktik bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Mehmet Scholl eschofiert sich über die Dreierkette, die gegen Italien eingesetzt wurde im Viertelfinale. Er hat da auch eine persönliche Note reingebracht. Die habe ich aber rausgeschnitten, weil er sich später dafür entschuldigt hat. Das wollen wir ihm nicht weiter vorhalten. Aber ihr bekommt schon einen Eindruck, um was es in diesem Tribünengespräch gehen soll, nämlich um Taktik und Spielanalyse. Und ich könnte mir keinen besseren Gesprächspartner vorstellen als derjenige, der mir jetzt live gegenüber sitzt. Und zwar Dr. Alexander Schmalhofer, Leiter des Fachbereichs Taktik und Spielanalyse am Institut für Fußballmanagement. Servus Herr Doktor. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ich glaube, wir können bei Alex bleiben. Wir stellen dich gleich noch näher vor. Bevor wir ins Thema reingehen, muss ich aber noch drei Hörern danken, nämlich Nicola Elischa Matmou, Christian Bien und den über Twitter sehr gut bekannten Ralf Heuer. Vielen Dank. Ihr drei habt uns unterstützt. Unser rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Von euch kommt übrigens auch alle Hardware, mit der heute aufgenommen wird, exklusive meines Laptops. Alles von den Hörern. Vielen Dank dafür. Alex nickt, alle kennen ihn. Ja, wir haben tolle Hörer. Vielen Dank dafür. Und wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das unter rasenfunk.de unterstützen tun. Und in diesem Sinne würde ich sagen, starten wir in ein Tribünengespräch, von dem wir, glaube ich, beide gespannt sind, über was wir heute alles sprechen werden. Spiel- und Taktikanalyse – für mich so ein bisschen eine Blackbox. Ich gucke da so leihenhaft von außen rein, versuche mir einen Reim drauf zu machen. Und du darfst mir heute erklären, was das eigentlich so bedeutet. Aber zunächst mal würde mich interessieren, wie bist du eigentlich zu dem Beruf gekommen? Das wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht von Anfang an ein Berufswunsch gewesen sein.
Ja, das stimmt. Erst mal auch, hallo von meiner Seite. Ich freue mich, dass ich hier sein darf. Ich wurde ja schon in höchsten Tönen gelobt und anmoderiert. Es ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, wie ich irgendwie in diesen Beruf auch so ein Stück weit reingerutscht bin. Ich habe natürlich mich, wie viele andere auch schon, schon viel immer mit Fußball auseinandergesetzt. Habe eine eigene kleine Spielerlaufbahn hinter mir. Habe in der Jugend unter anderem beim TSV 1860 München gespielt. Habe dann im Herrenbereich auch bis zur Regionalliga gespielt und habe da einfach als Spieler einige Erfahrungen sammeln können. Habe dann schon relativ früh auch entschieden, dass ich im Sport bleiben will. Das mich unglaublich fasziniert, auch dieser Leistungssport. Und habe dann ein Sportwissenschaftsstudium gemacht, in München auch. Habe währenddessen so meine Trainerscheine gemacht. Und bin dann eigentlich relativ nahtlos nach meiner aktiven Spielerlaufbahn, die ich eigentlich relativ früh schon beendet habe, zur Spielvereinigung Unterhach hingegangen. Habe daran, ich glaube, eineinhalb Jahre auch den ganzen Spielanalysebereich schon geleitet, sowohl für die erste Mannschaft als auch für das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Hintergrund, dass ich überhaupt den Schritt dorthin gegangen bin, war, dass ich direkt nach meinem Studium tatsächlich meine Doktorarbeit eben angefangen habe. Was weniger eigentlich den Hintergrund hatte, dass ich diesen Doktortitel unbedingt erwerben wollte, sondern sich beruflich für mich zu ergeben hat und ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, ob ich das tatsächlich machen will oder nicht. Und wenn ich es mache, dann muss es ein Thema sein, das mich unfassbar interessiert und das mich auch motiviert, eine lange Zeit auch so zu begleiten und zu beforschen, sage ich mal.
Was war das Thema deiner Doktorarbeit dann?
Das Thema war Perturbationsprofile im Nachwuchsleistungsfußball.
Das musst du ganz kurz, zumindest grob erklären. Was sind denn Perturbationsprofile?
Also ich erkläre mal den Begriff der Perturbation. Das ist im Grunde, um es kurz zu machen, ich habe jetzt keine Powerpoint-Präsentation. Im Grunde kommt das Ganze aus der Systemtheorie. Und wenn man sich jetzt beispielsweise ein Molekül vorstellt, das eine gewisse Anordnung von Atomen hat, dann ist es so, dass wenn dieses Atom oder das Molekül samt seiner Atome in ein Ungleichgewicht gerät, also in eine Unordnung kommt, dann muss es irgendwo mindestens eine Ursache, einen Auslöser dafür gegeben haben, dass es eben dieses Molekül in ein Ungleichgewicht gekommen ist. So, und übertragen auf das Sportspiel Fußball ist es so, dass wenn es zu einer Torchance oder zu einem Tor kommt, ich nenne es mal torkritische Situation, dann muss es bei der verteidigenden Mannschaft irgendwo mindestens eine Ursache dafür gegeben haben, dass es eben zu einem Ungleichgewicht gekommen ist. So, und diese Ursache nennt sich dann Perturbation. Und die habe ich erforscht und gesucht und habe das Ganze angewandt auf eine Stichprobe von Jugendmannschaften, um dann schon auch wieder sehr praxisnahe Erkenntnisse gewinnen zu können.
Krass. Wir müssen aber noch einen Schritt zurückgehen. Also zum einen, was wir höheren nicht sehen können, ist, du bist wahnsinnig jung. Zumindest siehst du wahnsinnig jung aus. Ich glaube, wir sind gar nicht so weit auseinander. Das heißt, du musst ja schon, also zum einen muss die Karriere früh geendet haben oder du musst früh mit dem Studium begonnen haben. Wie kam denn das? Hast du dann schon parallel zum Regionalligaspielen studiert oder kam das nacheinander?
Genau. Ich habe parallel zum Regionalligaspielen das Studieren angefangen und das war auch eine ganz gute Verbindung. Ich habe dann relativ knapp nach dem Studium mit der Doktorarbeit angefangen. Das ging irgendwie relativ nahtlos und ich habe jetzt beispielsweise auch kein Auslandssemester gemacht, sondern habe sehr viel Zeit wirklich da rein investiert. Zum einen, um in einem semi-professionellen Bereich meine Erfahrungen als Spieler zu sammeln und aber auch dieses Studium relativ schnell dadurch durchziehen zu können, was dann für mich den Vorteil hatte, dass ich aus dem ganzen recht jung hervorgegangen bin. Wobei, das ist etwas, wo man völlig wertvoller ist, weil jeder, der auch ein Auslandssemester oder ähnliches macht, natürlich unfassbar viele Erfahrungen mitbringt, vielleicht auch nochmal sich sprachlich deutlich weiterentwickeln kann. Das war so der Weg, den ich dann gegangen bin.
Welche Positionen hast du gespielt?
Ich habe Innenverteidiger gespielt, links Fuß.
Ah ja, gut, das ganze Spiel wird vorsichtig. Jetzt komme ich auch langsam darauf, warum du in der Doktorarbeit nachgucken wolltest, wo so die Fehler entstehen, die zu Torschausen führen.
Ja, das stimmt tatsächlich. Ich glaube schon, dass ich sehr motiviert daran war, weil mich schon immer fasziniert hat, Ursachen zu finden. Warum kommst du denn zu Torschausen? Ich glaube, dass jeder Spieler – und das ist völlig wurscht, ob der Bundesliga spielt oder Kreisliga spielt – reflektiert so ein Stück weit nach dem Spiel das Spiel. Und reflektiert auch, was habe ich jetzt vielleicht gut gemacht, was habe ich schlecht gemacht, was kann ich besser machen oder ähnliches. Und es bleiben ja nicht immer alle Momente im Spiel hängen, sondern es bleiben ja so ausgewählte Momente hängen. Und da gehören natürlich Tore und Torschausen immer ganz stark auch dazu. Und gleichzeitig sind es ergebnisrelevante Situationen im Fußball und haben somit natürlich einen deutlich höheren Wert auch. Und mir war es oftmals auch zu wenig Info und Input, was ich dann bekommen habe, sozusagen von dem Trainer oder von dem Co-Trainer. Ich wollte dann immer noch viel tiefer das Ganze auch wissen.
Es war jetzt aber nicht so, dass du als Verteidiger nachweisen wolltest, dass alle Fehler schon im Mittelfeld entstanden sind, bei jeder Torschausen.
Ach, vielleicht war es auch so.
Könnte man so vermuten.
Ich lasse es mal so dahingestellt. Ich glaube, als Verteidiger hat man immer eine schwierige Rolle. Aber nein, das hat dann weniger auch vielleicht mit mir persönlich zu tun, sondern einfach mit der Tatsache, noch mehr über den Fußball erfahren zu wollen und da einfach noch tiefer einsteigen zu wollen. Aber immer mit dem Hintergrund, dass ich auch jetzt zum Beispiel in so einer Doktorarbeit nichts entwickeln und beforschen will, was am Ende dann nicht auf den Platz angewandt werden kann, sondern es sollen immer trainingspraktische Maßnahmen daraus entstehen. Das ist etwas, was mich bis heute auch begleitet und was, glaube ich, für uns auch institutseitig am Fachbereich und auch meine Person einfach immer so ein Stück weit vielleicht auch ausgemacht hat.
Aber ich würde mal davon – ich würde die gewagte These ausstellen, nicht jeder Innenverteidiger in der Regionalliga geht so analytisch und akribisch an diese Sache ran. Woher kommt denn diese so analytische und tiefe Begeisterung für den Fußball? Wo hat denn das angefangen? War das dann tatsächlich, als es sich dann abgezeichnet hat, Regionalliga, man kommt in so ein professionelleres Umfeld rein? Oder kommt das schon aus deiner Jugend?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass mich das als Spieler begleitet hat. Ich glaube, dass ich insgesamt einfach ein Spieler war, der sehr viel sehr überlegt einfach schon gespielt hat. Das ist jetzt gar nicht gut oder schlecht, sondern es gibt ja eigentlich auch so in der Sportwissenschaft zwei Typen von Spielern. Das sind eigentlich die Spieler, die eher so ein bisschen überlegter spielen. Das sind meistens dann auch so die Sechserpositionen, die Innenverteidiger, die halt dann auch viel versuchen, sich selber und auch die Mannschaft zu positionieren. Und dann gibt es aber auch so ein bisschen diejenigen, die halt viel freier aufspielen, die eher so aus dem Bauch heraus spielen, sage ich mal, die aber genauso wichtig sind wie der andere Part sozusagen auch. Und deswegen glaube ich, hat mich das als Spieler schon tatsächlich immer sehr fasziniert. Und dadurch, dass ich dann einfach so einen bisschen wissenschaftlichen Weg auch eingeschlagen habe, wo man natürlich immer auch versuchen will, vieles zu belegen und vieles zu beweisen, kam dann dieser analytische Hintergrund einfach noch sehr stark dazu.
Und wie klappt das neben dem Regionalliga-Alltag noch zu studieren? Ich stelle es mir zeitaufwendig und anstrengend vor.
Ja, das stimmt. Wobei der Vorteil ist, diejenigen, die jetzt vielleicht auch gerade zuhören und Bayernliga oder Regionalliga spielen, die wissen, dass man sich da auch so ein bisschen Geld ja nebenbei verdienen kann, um sich so ein Sportstudium dann auch, ich sage mal, zumindest mit zu finanzieren. Und gleichzeitig war es für mich perfekt, weil ich im Studium unglaublich fit war. Wir haben total viel Sport gemacht. Das hat sich megamäßig ergänzt. Problematisch wurde es tatsächlich dann, als das Studium abgeschlossen war, als es dann beruflich so ein bisschen interessanter wurde, dann ist es schwieriger. Weil selbst in der Regionalliga ist es so, dass man auch mal drei, vier Stunden mit dem Bus einfach fährt und relativ viel trainiert. Und so ändert sich das dann. Und das war auch ein Grund, warum ich für mich damals in der Regionalliga gesagt habe, okay, jetzt liegt auch – das hört sich jetzt so von – das Angebot vor. Ich habe die Möglichkeit, in Unterhaching das Ganze beruflich umzusetzen. Dementsprechend werde ich mich jetzt auch auf den beruflichen Weg konzentrieren.
Das heißt, das war dann eine bewusste Entscheidung, raus aus dem Sport als Akteur, als auf dem Spieler Akteur rein, als Trainer quasi?
Richtig, kann man so sagen. Also es war eine sehr schwierige Entscheidung. Vor allem, ich habe beim TSV Buchbach gespielt, das darf man hier an der Stelle auch erwähnen, weil ich dafür gerne auch für den Verein Werbung mache, weil das ein unglaublich sympathischer Verein ist und ich eine tolle Zeit hatte und auch alles immer sehr wertschätzend war. Dann so auf die andere Seite zu wechseln, war schon was Besonderes, aber es hat mich auch unglaublich gereizt und dann auch vor allem die Möglichkeit zu haben, direkt im Profifußball erste Erfahrungen zu sammeln, war eine Riesenmöglichkeit, die mir damals dann auch die Spielvereinigung unter Hachin geboten hat. Und mit dem Background, den ich natürlich in meiner Ausbildung sozusagen hatte und das, was ich vielleicht auch ein Stück weit noch vorhabe, hat sich das einfach wunderbar ergänzt.
In welcher Zeit warst du dann bei Hachin? Wo haben die da gespielt?
Das war in der dritten Liga damals.
Und dann warst du sofort zuständig für Spielanalyse und taktische Vorbereitung von Profimannschaft und von den Jugendteams?
Es war so, dass in Unterhaching selber taktisch schon auf einem sehr hohen Niveau gearbeitet wurde. Oder wird es, denke ich, immer noch. Und ich sozusagen zu einer Zeit kam, wo eigentlich diese Position auch durchaus gefragt war. Dahingehend, dass man natürlich… Das ist eine gute Frage. Das war, glaube ich, im Winter 2013. Genau. Dass es halt viel auch darum ging, zum einen das zu evaluieren, was man als Spielkonzept schon sehr stark gearbeitet hatte. Also das ist so der Taktikaspekt, den du auch ansprichst. Und auf der anderen Seite halt wirklich auch im Sinne der Videoanalyse regelmäßig mit den Spielern zu arbeiten, Gegner vorbereitend zu arbeiten. Und das war, glaube ich, dann auch für den Verein so ein Stück weit vielleicht ein nächster Schritt der Entwicklung, auch dann eine Person neben den Trainern dazu zu holen, die sich darum auch mit kümmert. Und Nachwuchsleistungszentrum deswegen, weil diese klare Spielidee, die man in Unterhaching dann auch gepflegt hat, schon auch auf den Nachwuchsbereich heruntergebrochen werden sollte. Was auch sehr gut geklappt hat, muss ich sagen. Und deswegen war das eine total spannende Zeit, wo ich auch unglaublich viel gelernt habe von den damaligen Personen, die da waren und mich einfach dann sehr geprägt hat irgendwo auch inhaltlich.
Mit welchem Trainer hast du da noch zusammengearbeitet? Wer war in der Zeit bei Haching?
Als ich kam, waren Klaus Schromm Trainer und Manuel Baum. Das war eine Doppelspitze, die das damals gemacht haben, die auch inhaltlich sehr stark waren und schon ein unglaubliches taktisches Konzept hatten, als ich auch kam. Und dann war es eine Zeit, die dann leider kurzfristig, so ist es im Fußball, auch weniger erfolgreich mal war. Dann hat sich ein Trainerwechsel ergeben und dann kam Christian Ziege, den ich dann noch eine gewisse Zeit erlebt habe und auch da wieder sehr viel lernen habe können.
War das dann deren Idee, dich in dieser neuen Position zur Haching zu holen? Es hört sich so an, als würde diese Position mit dem Moment geschaffen, wo du gekommen bist. Oder gab es die vorher schon?
Nein, die gab es in der Form vorher nicht. Es war schon so eine Mischform, eine Co-Trainer-Tätigkeit, wenn man so will. Weil ich auch mit auf dem Platz war in vielen Einheiten, mich aber trotzdem auch intensiv um die Gegnervorbereitung gekümmert habe. Ich denke, es war ein weiterer Entwicklungsschritt, um vielleicht noch mehr rauszuholen aus der Mannschaft. Sowohl in der Entwicklung der Spieler als auch auf den Samstag, wo der Gegner auf dem Platz wartet.
Wenn du jetzt darauf zurückguckst, ist ja jetzt auch drei Jahre her, was würdest du sagen, sind so die Sachen, die du da in dieser aktiven Rolle gelernt hast?
Also zum einen habe ich, wie gesagt, inhaltlich unfassbar viel gelernt. Also beispielsweise auch von jemandem wie Manuel Baum, der jetzt Chef-Trainer im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum des FC Augsburg ist, war es sehr interessant, sag ich mal, so diesen Ballbesitzfußball, der damals in Unterhaching auch wirklich gepflegt wurde, eigentlich von der Seite kennenzulernen, wie ich ihn damals noch nicht kannte, wo es wirklich gezielt darum ging, Spieler in gewisse Positionen zu bringen, um irgendwo Überzahl zu schaffen und das wirklich so ein Stück weit zu automatisieren und auf dem Trainingsplatz und dann auch im Spiel umzusetzen. Also eigentlich eine Art und Weise, wie Pep Guardiola in München gearbeitet hat. Bloß muss ich sagen, dass wir teilweise vorher schon auch mit solchen Dingen gearbeitet haben. Das hört sich jetzt vielleicht vermessen an, aber es war tatsächlich so. Deswegen war es für mich inhaltlich unfassbar wertvoll, einfach den Fußball von einer anderen Seite kennenzulernen. Und gleichzeitig war es für mich auch eine unglaubliche Möglichkeit, mich als Persönlichkeit zu entwickeln, weil ich noch so jung war. Ich war damals teilweise gleich alt wie die ältesten Spieler und so noch, obwohl wir da auch eine sehr junge Mannschaft hatten. Das war dann auch nicht immer einfach, sage ich mal, aber trotzdem unglaublich lehrreich für mich auch.
Okay. Da hast du bestimmt viele Anekdoten mitgenommen, die du wahrscheinlich nicht alle hier erzählen darfst. Aber jetzt sitzen wir hier am Institut für Fußballmanagement. Das heißt, irgendwann musst du die Entscheidung getroffen haben, so reizvoll und schön die Aufgabe bei Haching war. Es geht hierher ans Institut. Wie ist es dazu gekommen?
Also ich muss dazu sagen, dass sich die Tätigkeit am Institut schon während der Zeit in Unterhaching mitentwickelt hat.
Machst du immer Dinge parallel? Studio, Regionalliga, Haching etc.
Nein, ich komme darauf zurück, weil ich jetzt eigentlich aktuell außerhalb von Projekten, die parallel laufen, nichts mehr parallel mache. Das war auch ein Grund, warum ich mich dann entschieden habe, voll ans Institut zu gehen, weil dieses Parallelmachen einfach viel Kraft gekostet hat, viel Zeit gekostet hat und ich mich dann einfach auch für eine Richtung entscheiden musste. Es gab aber eine Zeit, wo das parallel lief, in der ich dann aber auch irgendwann gesagt habe, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es, ich kann in Unterhaching bleiben, wo sicherlich interessante Möglichkeiten da waren. Auf der anderen Seite war aber das Institut für Fußballmanagement damals noch gar nicht so alt und war noch sehr stark in der Entwicklungsphase. Ich hatte auch die Möglichkeit, diesen Fachbereich Spiel- und Taktikanalyse, wie wir ihn damals getauft haben, von Kindesbeinen an mitzuentwickeln, was unfassbar interessant war, weil vor allem so in der Zeit, also hatte ich das Gefühl, so rund um 2013, 2014, sich zwar extrem viel in der Spielanalyse getan hat, wir aber noch lange nicht so weit waren, wie wir jetzt drei Jahre später sind. Auch in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung von Spielanalysen, egal ob quantitativ oder qualitativ, auch in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung der Personen, die das im Verein machen, da hat sich unfassbar viel getan. Und das war unglaublich reizvoll, diese Entwicklung mitzugehen und so einen Bereich ein Stück weit mitzuentwickeln. Und das hat soweit tatsächlich ganz gut geklappt.
Genau, hier sitzen wir jetzt im Institut für Fußballmanagement. Ich kannte euch ehrlich gesagt nicht, obwohl ihr auch in der Peripherie Münchens seid. Ich bin auf euch gestoßen, weil einer unserer Rasenfunkgäste hier tatsächlich das Zertifikat bei euch gemacht hat zum Spielanalysten und taktischen Beobachter. Deswegen erzähl doch mal ein bisschen, was macht das Institut eigentlich?
Also das Institut selbst, unabhängig von der Spielanalyse, ist eigentlich ein akademisches Forschungs- und Beratungsunternehmen, wenn man so will. Also wir beschäftigen uns mit verschiedenen Themen im Profifußball. Zum einen mit Themen, die sich eher im Bereich Fußballmanagement ansiedeln und dann Themen, die sich eher in der Sportwissenschaft ansiedeln. Wir versuchen dann einen sehr ganzheitlichen Ansatz zu verfolgen und beraten da eben auch Vereine, Verbände und Unternehmen, die im Profifußball tätig sind. Im Fußballmanagement sind es dann Themen wie Vermarktung, Sponsoring, Digitalisierung, wo du jetzt auch der absolute Top-Experte bist. Solche Themen in der Sportwissenschaft sind es dann Bereiche wie Talentförderung, auch Leistungsentwicklung und eben auch der Bereich Spielanalyse.
Und bei euch kann man sich ausbilden lassen. Also ihr bietet ein Zertifikat an. Was muss ich mir darunter vorstellen? Außer etwas, was ich mir in die Wand hängen kann, wenn ich es geschafft habe?
Ich hoffe, dass es dann zwar an der Wand hängt, aber dass man es dann tatsächlich auch anwenden kann. Also ich glaube, das Zertifikat, von dem du sprichst, ist das Hochschul-Zertifikat Spielanalyst Fußball. Das sehr angesiedelt ist eben an den Fachbereich Spiel- und Taktikanalyse. Und es geht darum, oder es ging auch von Beginn an darum, dieses Berufsbild des Spielanalysten einfach noch klarer zu definieren und noch klarer zu entwickeln. Und mit verschiedensten Aktionen, dazu gehört eben diese Weiterbildung, dieses Berufsbild auch so ein Stück weit nach außen hin zu kommunizieren. Angefangen hat dieses Berufsbild auch so ein bisschen damit, dass es immer in einem Verein einen gab, der saß meistens in irgendeinem Kabuff und hat dann irgendwelche Videoschnipsel zusammen.
Auf VHS wahrscheinlich.
Und hat das Ganze dann irgendwie zusammengestellt, hat es dann dem Trainer bestenfalls übergeben. Und der Trainer hat dann irgendwie damit weitergearbeitet und so. Ich erzähle sie so ein bisschen provokativ, aber sage ich mal Personen, deren Kompetenzen teilweise eigentlich so ein Stück weit verschenkt wurden, weil sie sehr analytisch eigentlich an solche Sachen herangegangen sind. Und so hat sich das Ganze auch entwickelt bis zu einem Stand, an dem wir uns jetzt befinden, wo sich das Berufsbild an der Spielanalyst oder auch der Co-Trainer analytisch schimpft, der tatsächlich wesentlicher Teil des Trainerteams ist, der sehr intensiv an der Entwicklung der eigenen Spielphilosophie beteiligt ist, der sehr intensiv auch sich auf einen Gegner vorbereitet, somit eigentlich sehr kompetenter Berater eigentlich auch des Cheftrainers ist, der im Scouting, sprich wirklich in der Kaderplanung oft noch integriert ist und somit eigentlich ein sehr breites Aufgabenfeld hat. Und das bedarf einfach einiger Kompetenzen, die er können muss, sage ich mal. Und es gab dann einfach in dem Bereich keine Möglichkeit, sich wirklich intensiv auszubilden. Und so haben wir dieses Zertifikat konzipiert vor drei Jahren eigentlich, sind jetzt im zweiten Lehrgang. Und das hat sich tatsächlich sehr stark bewährt. Und der Markt hat es extrem gut angenommen, weil er gesehen hat, okay, hier kann ich mich sehr praxisnah fortbilden und die Dinge dann auch umsetzen.
Wie läuft so ein Zertifikat dann ab? Es ist vermutlich nicht so, dass man fünf Tage die Woche die Schulbank drückt, sondern ihr werdet das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders gestaltet haben.
Genau, also wir pflegen ein sogenanntes semi-virtuelles Lernformat. Das heißt nichts anderes, als dass man bei uns insgesamt im Zertifikat, ich glaube sieben Monate teilnimmt und man hat eigentlich jeden Monat ein anderes Modul mit anderen Inhalten. Und jeden Monat ist man dann auch zwei Präsenztage vor Ort in Ismaning bei uns und man beschäftigt sich mit diesen Inhalten, auf die ich gerne noch eingehe im späteren. Und wenn man eben nicht bei uns ist, dann hat man die Möglichkeit, über eine Lernplattform auch die Inhalte im Nachhinein nochmal zu bearbeiten, die Präsentationen, die dann von dem jeweiligen Dozenten erstellt werden, von dort abzurufen, Videos anzuschauen, Aufgabenstellungen zu bearbeiten. Und so sind es immer intensive Workshop-Tage. Aber dadurch, dass die meisten, die auch das Zertifikat machen, beruflich einfach voll eingespannt sind, auch viele eben schon in den Vereinen, dass das einfach so ein bisschen flexibel auch machbar ist.
Was sind das so für Leute, die das Zertifikat bei euch machen jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahrgängen?
Also es sind tatsächlich aktive Spielanalysten aus den Nachwuchsleistungszentren oder auch schon teilweise aus dem Profibereich, sowohl aus Deutschland oder Österreich. Es sind aber auch viele Trainer, die so ihren analytischen Background eigentlich weiter vertiefen wollen, weil man sich einfach auch sehr intensiv um diese taktischen Aspekte natürlich auch bemüht und auseinandersetzt. Dann haben wir auch Sportstudenten natürlich, die so einen Weg einschlagen wollen. Wir haben Sportjournalisten, die so ein Stück weit ihre Berichterstattung, ich nenne es mal, optimieren wollen. Und genau, haben einige Scouts noch, die vor allem dann so im Sinne der Einzelspieleranalyse den optimalen Wurf machen wollen natürlich.
Und wie ist das Verhältnis zwischen Männer und Frauen?
Wir haben dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal eine Frau dabei.
Da ist noch einiges zu tun.
Ja, absolut. Da ist auch der Frauenfußball durchaus gefragt, da gerne teilzunehmen. Also wir sind da total offen, selbstverständlich.
Ja, nicht nur der Frauenfußball, es soll einfach mehr Frauen im Fußball geben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Kommt auch noch dazu, das stimmt.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir, was du gemacht hast und was du jetzt gerade tust. Dann können wir jetzt eigentlich einsteigen. Und du darfst mir mal erklären, wie funktioniert Spielanalyse. Es gibt wahrscheinlich verschiedene Arten, sich dem zu nähern. Wahrscheinlich einen total akademischen Weg. Den lassen wir jetzt mal weg. Du darfst gerne immer wieder akademisch werden. Ich fange dich dann wieder ein. Aber lass mal einfach im kleinen Beginn. Wie siehst du, wenn du jetzt in deiner Analystenrolle ein Spiel siehst, wahrscheinlich kannst du es anders gar nicht mehr, wie siehst du ein Fußballspiel?
Boah, das ist jetzt so eine riesen Frage, wo ich versuchen muss, auf den Punkt zu kommen. Also wenn ich ein Spiel sehe, dann beurteile ich es ja schon mal qualitativ. Das heißt, das hat ja zunächst mal mit Spieldaten zum Beispiel nichts zu tun, wo ich schon bei der ersten Unterteilung zwischen quantitativ und qualitativ bin, was vielleicht einen akademischen Hauch hat. Aber ich glaube jeder, der sich mit Spielanalyse beschäftigt, egal ob Medien, im Verein oder auch Fußballfans, ziehen immer wieder Daten zu, um gewisse Dinge zu interpretieren.
Klar, der berühmte Ballbesitz.
Ja, da kann ich auch…
Hacking, da reden wir später drüber.
Da gibt es auch die ein oder andere lustige Anekdote. Das heißt, wenn ich das Spiel anschaue, dann ist es eben auf eine qualitative Art und Weise. Und dann geht es im Grunde fast wie für einen Trainer auch um das Spiel mit dem Ball und um das Spiel gegen den Ball. Ich muss zunächst natürlich mal unterteilen, analysiere ich den Gegner, analysiere ich die eigene Mannschaft, analysiere es vielleicht auch neutral eben für Medien beispielsweise. Im Vordergrund steht so ein Stück weit eigentlich Muster zu erkennen bei einer Mannschaft. Jetzt nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Gegneranalyse, weil es sich übertragen lässt auch auf die Eigenanalyse zum Beispiel. Es ist so, dass eine Mannschaft immer einen gewissen Plan hat. Wie spielt sie gegen den Ball? Wie läuft sie an? Wo lenkt sie hin? Aus welcher Grundordnung bzw. aus welchem System spielt sie heraus? Was tut sie im Umschalten nach einem Ballverlust zum Beispiel? Also geht sie ins Gegenpressing, das ist ja immer sehr viel diskutiert, oder hält sie die Höhe, um die Initialaktion erstmal zu unterbinden, oder sagt sie gleich, ich verschwinde in die eigene Hälfte, macht ihr mal, ich will den Ball gar nicht gleich wieder erobern. Genau das Gleiche ist für das Spiel mit dem Ball einer Mannschaft. Oder wenn wir beim Gegner bleiben, wie eröffnet der Gegner das Spiel? Also gibt es da irgendwelche Muster, die zu erkennen sind? Spielen die immer durchs Zentrum, immer über die Flügel? Haben wir Positionswechsel in der Spieleröffnung? Da bin ich wieder bei Pep Guardiola zum Beispiel. Also die klassische Dreierkette, die er aus einer Viererkette dann immer gebildet hat. Dann ist die Frage, was passiert im Übergangsspiel? Also zwischen Spieleröffnung und dem vordersten Drittel sozusagen. Also gibt es da auch Positionswechsel? Wie wollen dann auch konkret im vorderen Drittel Tore und Torschancen erspielt werden? Also was für Muster sind da vielleicht zu erkennen? Wie wird auch der Mittelstürmer eingesetzt, um die Europameisterschaft mal so ein Stück weit ins Spiel zu bringen? Genau, das ist so grob auf der mannschaftstaktischen Ebene. Und dann kann ich natürlich immer tiefer einsteigen, auch mir anschauen, was sind die Stärken und Schwächen des Einzelspielers, sowohl technisch als auch taktisch. Und ich habe da natürlich Riesenmöglichkeiten. Und das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel, wie man das rein qualitativ dann auch beurteilen kann.
Ich habe dazu zwei Fragen.
Das ist aber wenig.
Na ja, Moment mal, da kennst du mein Sendungsdokument nicht. Die sind legendär bei Rasenfunk. Es geht schon noch weiter. Du hast gesagt, jede Mannschaft hat einen Plan. Hast du das Auftaktspiel von Werder Bremen bei den Bayern gesehen, in der Bundesliga? Denn ich würde – also ich will jetzt nicht irgendwelche Träne dissen. Und ich will jetzt auch nicht so tun, als ob manche Mannschaften attraktiv spielen würden. Aber ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass es auch jetzt in der Bundesliga und auch in der zweiten Liga Mannschaften gibt, die nicht in jeder Situation eine klare Ansage haben, was sie zu tun haben. Sondern zum Teil habe ich den Eindruck, es ist eher so der individuellen Entscheidung der Spieler geschuldet. Und so hatte ich es zum Beispiel bei Bremen im Auftaktspiel, finde ich, sah das auch so gegen den Ball. Hattest du so eine ganz komische Mischung aus Raum- und Mannendeckung. Und ein Spieler ist mal vorne draufgegangen, wenn er ein Ball verloren hat. Dann hat er sich umgedreht und dann waren alle anderen schon auf der A9 wieder Richtung Bremen. Das wäre jetzt meine erste Frage. Ist es wirklich so, dass alle Mannschaften einen Plan haben? Oder bewertet man das nicht vielleicht auch da an dem Punkt schon ein bisschen über?
Ja, das mag sein. Also auch keinen Plan zu haben, ist ja ein Plan zu haben, jetzt mal provokativ gesagt. Deswegen habe ich jetzt so angesprochen, dass jede Mannschaft so eine grundsätzliche Idee hat. Ich gehe jetzt nicht darauf ein, wie das Bremen in München gestaltet hat. Ich glaube, dass es schief gegangen ist. Das ist ein höflicher Mensch. Ja, natürlich. Ich glaube eher, dass es tatsächlich unglaublich Mannschaftsspezifisch ist, wie ausgereift dieser Plan ausgearbeitet ist. Ich bin der Meinung, dass eigentlich auch alle Mannschaften in der Bundesliga oder ich sage mal auch im deutschen Profifußball einen schon sehr gut ausgereiften Plan im Spiel gegen den Ball haben. Einfach auch deswegen, weil es deutlich einfacher ist zu trainieren und umzusetzen, weil ich eigentlich meinen Spielern eine Lösungsmöglichkeit an die Hand gebe. Das ist jetzt nicht im Detail in jeder Spielsituation so, aber wenn ich es vielleicht so ein Stück weit mannschaftstaktisch betrachte, dann kann ich ihnen eigentlich eine Lösung geben und ganz klar ansagen, wie ich anlaufen will, wo ich gerne den Ball erobern will, was ich einfach in so Schlüsselmomenten machen will, und kann diese Situation auch im Training schön bearbeiten. Also kann ich das auch mit Videoanalyse sehr stark trainieren und ich orientiere mich eben beim Gegner dann sehr stark am Ball. Es wird schon deutlich komplexer, wenn ich den Ball selber habe. Ich persönlich finde, dass sich so ein bisschen die Spreu vom Weizen trennt im Spiel mit dem Ball. Also was machen die Mannschaften, wenn die den Ball haben? Haben die klare und coole, kreative Ideen, um genau gegen dieses sehr gute defensives System des Gegners Lösungen zu finden? Da habe ich mehrere Faktoren, die ich einbeziehen muss. Ich habe das Gegnerverhalten, ich habe das eigene Mitspielerverhalten, ich habe den Ort, wo ich auch selber den Ball habe. Das ist einfach deutlich schwieriger zu trainieren. Das ist auch nicht so, wie vielleicht in anderen Sportarten, in denen ich klare Spielzüge von ganz hinten bis nach ganz vorne fertig trainieren kann. Da komme ich jetzt zum Torabschluss. Das ist etwas, was ich total interessant finde, auch im modernen Fußball, wie sich das einfach weiterhin entwickelt. Ich glaube, dass Defensivkonzepte schon sehr gut entwickelt sind, auch wenn sie vielleicht mal nicht funktionieren. Ich glaube, das Offensivspiel hat einfach noch Luft nach oben.
Wie viele Mannschaften in der Bundesliga, würdest du denn sagen, gibt es, die gut im Ballbesitz sind, die dir als Profi bei dem, was sie machen, wenn sie den Ball haben, gefallen? Denn ich als Halbleier hätte gesagt, da fallen mir ehrlich gesagt nur fünf, sechs. Wenn ich wohlwollend bin, vielleicht acht ein, wo ich sage, die spielen quasi in einem Stil.
Das ist eine fiese Frage, weil ich tatsächlich auch gerade an fünf, sechs denke und sie gerne auch, oder davon drei oder vier, auch gerne begründe. Ich aber auch dazu sagen muss, dass ich vor allem jetzt in der aktuellen Saison noch nicht alle 18 Mannschaften so intensiv angeschaut habe, dass ich mir da so ein Urteil bilden könnte, sage ich mal.
Ja, wir kommen beide aus dem Urlaub, muss man dazu sagen. Deswegen seid ihr das sehr verziehen.
Und die Saison ist ja auch noch nicht so alt. Und jetzt irgendwie sich auf die letzte Saison zu beziehen, dafür ist, glaube ich, der Fußball ein zu aktuelles Tagesgeschäft einfach. Ich glaube aber, dass ich – also ich bin total gespannt, wie sich der FC Bayern entwickeln wird jetzt auch mit dem neuen Trainer Angelotti, der einfach das Erbe von Guardiola übernommen hat. Ich glaube, von Guardiola kann man erst mal halten, was man will. Ich denke, dass er den Ballbesitz Fußball in Deutschland einfach auf ein höheres Niveau gebracht hat. Auch was das allgemeine Verständnis dieses Ballbesitzfußballs betrifft, was auch wiederum Auswirkungen auf die Art und Weise des Fußballs in der Nationalmannschaft hatte. Ich finde auch, dass sich Borussia Dortmund z.B. extrem weiterentwickelt hat unter Thomas Tuchel. Während bei Klopp schon eher der Umschaltfußball im Vordergrund stand, hat Klopp z.B. dieses Ballbesitzspiel viel mehr implementiert und ist dadurch mit Dortmund viel variabler geworden. Ob der Erfolg ist, der dann hinten dabei herauskommt, ist die Frage. Aber so ist die Art und Weise, wie er den Ball hat. Leverkusen finde ich genauso, die eine lange Zeit viel auf den zweiten Ball gespielt haben. Sehr viel versucht haben, in ein Gegenpressing zu gehen und dadurch viele Dinge zu provozieren, die sich in ihrer Spielanlage extrem weiterentwickelt haben. Borussia Mönchengladbach genauso.
Das wären die Namen gewesen, auf die ich gekommen wäre. Dann gibt es noch ein paar Teams, die schon einen Stil verfolgen. Du hast einen VfL Wolfsburg, der in der letzten Saison eines der ganz wenigen Teams war, mit einer positiven Ballbesitzbilanz. Die hatten oft den Ball und mussten deswegen auch oft etwas damit anfangen. Mit viel auf die Flügel raus. Sie haben es aber nicht so ganz geschafft, diesen Cut von De Bruyne und Perisic hinzukriegen. Die konntest du mit einer viel höheren Geschwindigkeit in den Raum schicken. Das ging mit Draxler und Schönen in der letzten Saison nicht so. In der Saison bin ich gespannt, wie es jetzt wird.
Und De Bruyne – Entschuldige, dass Sie mich unterbrechen. Man hat es ja bei der Europameisterschaft auch gesehen, was für ein unfassbar geiler Umschaltspieler Kevin De Bruyne ist. Da waren natürlich noch zwei, drei andere dabei, die das extrem gut gemacht haben. Aber auch zusammen mit Perisic war das für Wolfsburg einfach eine Waffe. Und so der Abgang von De Bruyne, da hatte ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass ihnen dadurch diese Waffe ein bisschen weggenommen wurde. Und sie haben es einfach nicht geschafft, auch dann im – ich nenne es mal – Herausspielen von Toren und Torchancen eine neue Waffe zu kreieren. Sei es wieder im Umschaltspiel oder dann auch im kontrollierten Ballbesitzspiel. Und ich glaube, dass das auch für Wolfsburg ein Entwicklungsschritt sein kann, mit dem man da durchaus anstreben kann.
Da ist man ja bei der alten Frage, richte ich mich nach den Spielern aus oder richte ich die Spieler nach meiner Art, Fußball spielen zu wollen aus? Und ich finde, das ist genau eins der Beispiele, wo man sagen kann, so kannst du halt mit Draxler und Schürrle nicht spielen. Schürrle hätte ich sogar noch eher zugetraut, allein von der Geschwindigkeit her, einfach in seinen vertikalen Läufen. Und es gab quasi keinen gut genugen Plan B in der letzten Saison. Und deswegen hat das nicht, ich meine, Achterplatz weit hinter den Erwartungen.
Deswegen bin ich da auch sehr gespannt, was diese Saison auch passieren wird in Wolfsburg. Ich glaube aber, dass da schon ein großes Potenzial in jedem Fall da ist.
Ach Gott, ich hätte so Lust, jetzt mit dir alle 18 Vereine durchzugehen.
Ja, aber da würdest du mich auch oftmals auf den falschen Fuß erwischen.
Das würde man ja bei dir gar nicht machen. Aber die Sache ist ja, die Tribünengespräche sollen zeitlose Formate sein, die man sich jederzeit anhören kann. Und das tun die Hörer auch. Deswegen hängen wir es mal nicht zu sehr an aktuellen Beispielen auf. Aber wir sind ein bisschen weggekommen. Ich hatte ja noch eine zweite Frage, die sich auf etwas bezieht, was du jetzt wahrscheinlich vor zehn Minuten gesagt hast. Und zwar hast du gesagt, es geht dir darum, Muster zu erkennen. Und das finde ich einen interessanten Gedanken aus zwei Gründen. Zum einen finde ich, ist es das total naheliegend. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was eigentlich alle Leute machen, die halbwegs analytisch Fußballspiele gucken. Irgendwann fällt einem einfach auf, Moment mal, die kommen immer über den Fliegel oder Moment mal, warum sind die denn hinten auf der linken Seite immer in Unterzahl? Und dann hat es entweder damit zu tun, dass der Gegner etwas Schlaues gemacht hat. Nein, eigentlich hat es immer mit beiden zu tun. Aber das ist total ein Loch, dass es um Muster geht. Und so bilden sich ja dann auch nicht nur Klischees, sondern auch richtige… Also wir haben jetzt gerade schon zwei, drei Mannschaften besprochen. Da waren wir uns relativ einig, wie die eigentlich spielen. Was ich mich nur bei dieser Sache frage, ist, was machen wir denn dann mit Dingen, bei denen der Trainer der Mannschaft gesagt hat, setz das ganz punktuell ein? Weil ich habe den Eindruck, das ist so fast die Sache, die im modernen Fußball noch eine unterschätzte Waffe ist. Es gibt verschiedene Phasen in Spielen. Das sieht man jetzt auch, dass es Mannschaften gibt, die zumindest sieht es so aus, die 15 Minuten ganz hoch Druck machen. Juwe bei Bayern in der letzten Saison im Rückspiel ganz weit vorne draufgegangen, im Spielaufbau gestört, nach 20 Minuten zurückgezogen. Was mache ich denn mit so punktuellen Geschichten? Ist da nicht so ein bisschen die Gefahr, dass ich die unter den Tisch fallen lasse, weil ich mich nur auf das beschränke, was sich ständig wiederholt?
Ja, absolut. Also zwei Beispiele dazu. Du hast jetzt Juve genannt, ich würde mal Athletico nennen auch letzte Saison. Das wird ja wieder ein aktuelles Thema. Da war es im Spiel gegen den Ball. Da war es unglaublich interessant zu sehen, wie Athletico verteidigt hat. Zum Teil ganz aggressiv vorne im Angriffspressing. Die Bayern oder auch schon vorher Barcelona, die damit richtig Stress hatten, überhaupt gar nicht das Spiel eröffnen lassen, hatten da eine Zeit gehabt, wo sie im Mittelfellpressing ganz gemütlich agiert haben, mit verschoben haben und hatten dann aber auch Phasen, wo sie wirklich komplett im Abwehrpressing waren, am eigenen 16er das Ballwerk aufgebaut haben. Das sind ja auch Muster. In dem Fall sind es drei Muster und nicht ein Muster, wie man glaubt, dass es eine Mannschaft immer macht. Ich glaube, der elementare Punkt ist einfach, dagegen immer Lösungen zu finden. In dem Fall haben die Bayern drei Lösungen gebraucht, gegen den ihr mannschaftstaktisches Anlauf verhalten. Ich kann das Ganze sehr weit runterbrechen. Ich kann es bis zum Einzelspieler runterbrechen und mir immer noch die Muster eines Einzelspielers anschauen. Ist das ein Arjen Robben, der immer gerne in die Mitte zieht? Oder ist das jemand, der breit bleibt? Und so kann ich es in der Defensive bei einem Innenverteidiger und seinem Verhalten auch machen. Ich glaube, es ist eine Gratwanderung, wie weit ich in die Tiefe einsteige. Und ich glaube, es ist auch eine Kunst des Cheftrainers zu entscheiden, wie viel Information ich meinem Spieler gebe – also direkt, indem ich es ihm sage oder in der Videoanalyse zeige. Wie viel Information gebe ich ihm vielleicht auch indirekt über mein Training, indem ich gewisse Dinge provoziere. Und das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich immer eine ganz, ganz schwierige Frage. Und dann, um zum zweiten Beispiel zu kommen, es gibt mittlerweile auch Mannschaften, die ganz bewusst versuchen, solche Muster zu brechen. Und zu sagen, wir versuchen gar keine Muster irgendwie einen Tag zu legen. Wir wollen da relativ transparent sein, wenn man so will. Was auch ein total interessanter Ansatz ist.
Wie meinst du damit? Ist das schon auch so eine Mannschaft wie Leverkusen? Oder sind da noch genügend Muster zu sehen? Aber die spielen ja so ein bisschen schwarmartig, zumindest gegen den Ball, finde ich.
Das stimmt. Und das ist aber auch so eine Art. Also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel Salzburg oder auch Leipzig anschaue, dann ist das schon sehr stark auch, habe ich das Gefühl, darauf aus genau solche Muster nicht erkennen zu lassen. Und sehr aggressiv immer nach vorne zu verteidigen und viel Unordnung vielleicht auch im Spiel zu nutzen beim Gegner. Aber wir befinden uns ja in den Spielphasen nicht immer in der Ordnung und können sagen, so jetzt bauen wir gemütlich auf. Sondern das Spiel hat ja einen unglaublich hohen Anteil auch an ungeordneten Situationen. Und in ungeordneten Situationen habe ich auch kein Muster. Und wie gesagt, das sind Punkte, die da total spannend sind und auch sicherlich kreativ sind.
Braucht man ja total schlaue Spiele dafür. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja, aber ein interessantes.
Ja, lass uns zu dem, was sich da generell so getan hat, später noch ein bisschen kommen. Jetzt würde mich noch mal so interessieren, um einfach das zu verstehen, was du täglich in deinem Job machst. Du hast jetzt gesagt, wie du dir Spiele anguckst, ist es klar, dass du dich entscheiden musst. Also wenn ich dir jetzt sage, analysieren wir mal beide Mannschaften bis ins Detail, dann wirst du ein Spiel mehrmals sehen müssen, denn das geht nicht alles gleichzeitig. In welcher Perspektive musst du es gucken? Taktikcam oder ist noch besser auf der Tribüne? Was wäre die ideale Position für dich, um ein Spiel zu analysieren?
Also die ideale Position ist tatsächlich, die Möglichkeit zu haben, das ganze Spielfeld zu sehen. Ob das dann über live im Stadion ist oder auch über eine bestimmte Kameraperspektive, die möglich ist, vor allem auch in der Bundesliga und in der zweiten Bundesliga. Da gibt es ein sogenanntes Scouting-Feed, das separat in den Stadien installiert ist, um immer die komplette Bandbreite des Spiels sehen zu können. Da ist das Fernsehbild ein Witz dagegen, sage ich mal. Das ist in jedem Fall die perfekte Perspektive, weil sich einfach sehr vieles ballentfernt abspielt. Aber auch da ist es im Grunde so, dass wir jetzt, wenn wir beispielsweise für Vereine arbeiten, dann hängt es auch davon ab, welche Möglichkeiten haben wir zur Verfügung. Also haben wir in der Bundesliga und der zweiten Bundesliga diese Scouting-Feed zum Beispiel, wo wir dann wirklich von oben alles sehen können? Oder sind wir vielleicht noch eine Liga oder zwei drunter, in denen vielleicht auch die Kameraperspektive gar nicht möglich ist, weil man die hohe Tribüne gar nicht hat? Also sind wir auch voll im Amateurfußball, in dem die Spielanalyse im Übrigen aber auch interessant ist? Oder ist es so, dass wir uns zum Beispiel in der Champions League befinden, dann hast du das Problem, dass du entweder live vor Ort sein kannst, dann siehst du das gesamte Spiel. Wenn du das nicht bist, dann hast du nur das Videomaterial Fernsehbild. Da gibt es zum Beispiel keinen Scouting-Feed.
Das ist ja verrückt. Und das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt. Du bist ja dafür zuständig. Ich glaube, das können wir ja sagen, dass das Teil deines Jobs ist, auch Champions League zu analysieren.
Genau, richtig. Also wir sind fürs ZDF tätig, ich selber auch als Fachberater von Oliver Kahn. Die Kahn-Alysen. Ja, so intensiv müssen wir da gar nicht einsteigen. Kahn-Alysen ist noch mal was Eigenes. Aber da sind wir einfach in einer engen Abstimmung.
Das heißt, du bist dann da mit vor Ort dann. Und deswegen bist du nicht nur aufs Fernsehmaterial angewiesen. Wie läuft denn so was ab? Also ich kann mir recht gut vorstellen, wie das Briefing davor laufen wird. Sowas habe ich auch schon früher, als ich noch sportjournalistisch tätig war, oft genug gesehen. Wie ebenso taktische Vorab-Analysen aussehen. Das ist ja quasi ein Teil der Spielanalyse. Ich bereite mich auf ein Spiel vor. Und dann gibt es ja den viel spannenderen Teil, wo sich wahrscheinlich auch die Spreu vom Weizen trennt, der Live-Analyse. Ist es dann auch tatsächlich so, dass du kurz vor Ende der Halbzeit dich mit Oliver Kahn besprichst, ihr die Dinge sagt, die euch beiden aufgefallen sind, sodass er in der Halbzeit dann zumindest noch eine zweite Meinung vorher gehört hat? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Genau, also so kann man sich das ungefähr vorstellen. Ich würde es aber tatsächlich eher am Beispiel eines Analysten im Verein festmachen, weil das eine ähnliche Art und Weise ist und vielleicht auch ein bisschen interessanter. Es ist eigentlich mittlerweile so ein Stück weit Gang und Gebe, dass die Analysten eben einen Superplatz oben auf der Tribüne haben. Das heißt, die haben da auch schon die komplette View auf den Platz, haben die Möglichkeit, auch schon mit technischen Mitteln, mit Videoanalyseprogrammen auch ein Live-Bild, das reinläuft sozusagen in das Notebook, auch schon zu bearbeiten, um dann in der Halbzeit auch Kontakt aufzunehmen, beispielsweise mit dem Cheftrainer, um essentielle Dinge dann auch zu besprechen. Das ist nochmal eine Möglichkeit, wie man einfach in der Live-Analyse da einwirken kann.
Was muss man können, um guter Spielanalyst zu sein? Ich würde sagen, eine Sache hat sich gerade schon herausgearbeitet. Ich muss multitasking können, denn wenn ich ein Schnittprogramm bedienen soll, während das Spiel ja weiterläuft, dann muss ich ja schon mal dafür die Fähigkeit haben. Was würdest du sagen, sind noch so Eigenschaften, die man haben sollte, wenn man Spielanalyst sein möchte?
Das ist eine gute Frage, weil das natürlich was ist, womit wir uns intensiv beschäftigt haben, auch im Zuge der Ausbildung, die wir entwickelt haben. Deswegen will ich, glaube ich, gar nicht darauf unbedingt hinaus, was man mitbringt, sondern was man vielleicht auch als Analyst an Kompetenzen einfach benötigt. Ich glaube, dass man schon eine gewisse Affinität auch zur Wissenschaft mitbringen sollte, weil Spielanalyse für mich auch so ein Mittelding ist aus Fußballforschung und Fußballpraxis. Zum einen, weil man schon sehr viel mit Daten arbeiten kann, vor allem wenn man es im professionellen Umfeld tut. Und zum anderen, weil man auch meines Erachtens sehr konzeptionell arbeitet, was für mich auch so ein Stück einfach so einen akademischen Aspekt hat. Das kann mit Sicherheit auch jemand, der keinen sportwissenschaftlichen Hintergrund oder Ähnliches hat, aber einfach so eine klare Struktur zu schaffen, etwas zu evaluieren, Wirksamkeit zu messen, hat in dem Zusammenhang, glaube ich, schon eine bedeutende Rolle. Dann sind es, denke ich, videotechnische Aspekte, die man mitbringen sollte. Also, dass man einfach in der Lage ist, zum Beispiel in der Gegnervorbereitung so ein Video zu schneiden, aber auch zu visualisieren. Also, dass nicht nur das Spiel einfach abläuft, sondern dass klar ist, hey, worum geht es jetzt, um welchen Spieler, um welche Bewegung der gegnerischen Viererkette zum Beispiel. Das hat dann auch viel mit Vermittlung zu tun, auch beim Trainer, auch, sage ich mal, die Dinge gut anzubringen auch, was nicht immer einfach ist, weil im Trainerstab ist vielleicht dann der andere Co-Trainer mal noch anderer Meinung. Und dann sind das natürlich auch immer interessante Gespräche. Und dann sind es natürlich tatsächlich auch eben viel taktische Dinge, die eine Rolle spielen, was dann mit dem eigenen Auge zu tun hat. Und woher man diese taktischen Dinge hat, glaube ich, spielt gar nicht so eine Rolle. Ich glaube, dass es diejenigen gibt, die einfach eine unglaubliche Spielerkarriere hingelegt haben, unfassbar viele Erfahrungen dadurch gesammelt haben und dadurch ein sehr großes Wissen mitbringen. Ich glaube, dass viele, aber auch der Fußballfan mittlerweile, sich in viele Dinge einliest oder vielleicht auch sowas hört, wie wir hier gerade fabrizieren.
Kann sein.
Und dadurch auch sehr viel Inhalt sich irgendwie aneignet. Das sind so Punkte, die ich da als elementar ansehe.
Damit hast du ja die komplette Laptop-Trainer vs. Ex-Profis-als-Trainer-Debatte, die Mehmet Schäumer aufgemacht hat, hast du ja schon in Grund und Boden argumentiert. Es gibt einfach auf beiden Seiten gute Trainer.
100% richtig, ja.
Lass uns mal über die Vorbereitung offen auf ein Spiel sprechen. Wir nehmen jetzt einfach an, Bayern spielt gegen Real Madrid, Champions League. Wie viele Spiele von Real Madrid zurück guckst du dir in der Regel an, um die Muster, über die wir gesprochen haben, zu erkennen? Kann man das auf eine Zahl feststellen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich kann man es schon. Zunächst ist es wichtig zu erwähnen, dass es nicht zwangsläufig die letzten drei oder vier Spiele sein müssen, sondern dass es schon ein Stück weit gegnerabhängig ist. Madrid hat die letzten drei oder vier Spiele gegen Mannschaften aus dem Tabellenkeller gespielt. Dann interessiert mich das als Bayern München erst mal nicht so, weil das ist ein anderes Spiel. Wenn jetzt aber in den letzten drei Spielen zweimal auch das Spiel gegen Barcelona war oder vielleicht auch eine andere Mannschaft, die ein bisschen vergleichbar ist mit mir, dann sind die Spiele schon deutlich interessanter. Dann ist es auch wieder davon abhängig, wie intensiv man es betreibt. Aber ich würde mal sagen, drei Spiele, vier Spiele sind es eigentlich schon.
Und wie lange dauert es, ein Spiel zu analysieren? Du musst jetzt grobe Schätzwerte abgeben, weil jedes Spiel anders ist. Aber du wirst ja wahrscheinlich ständig die Dinge noch ein zweites Mal angucken müssen. Oder es ist eine Chance entstanden. Und dann sagst du, Moment mal, jetzt weiß ich nicht, wo hier die Perputation stattgefunden hat. Härturbation, Entschuldigung. Oh Gott, das wäre ich gleich rausgeschmissen. Dann musst du wieder zurückspielen. Kann man das so runterbrechen? Wie lange sitzt man da so an einem Spiel im Schnitt?
Das ist jetzt schwierig.
Ja, das sind so doofe Leinenfragen. Das tut mir leid.
Das ist eine völlig legitime Frage. Aber der Punkt ist, es kommt ja immer noch deutlich mehr Workflow dazu, als sich das Spiel anzuschauen. Also es muss ja noch geschnitten werden und weiterverarbeitet werden. Die Frage nimmt man das dann mit dazu. Aber ich sage es jetzt mal tatsächlich einfach, okay, das Spiel anschauen, vielleicht eine Stunde.
Ah, okay, also sogar weniger als die eigentliche Spielzeit.
Ja, also ich glaube, je öfter man das macht, desto – also bei mir ist es aktuell zumindest so, dass ich dann aktuell ein bisschen weniger brauche, weil ich über viele Dinge einfach hinwegspringen kann. Es kommt aber auch echt drauf an, wenn ich jetzt – also wer ist derjenige, für den ich es mache, sage ich mal. Also wenn es jetzt vielleicht in Richtung Medien geht, wo ich weiß, da kommt es jetzt nicht aufs allerletzte Detail an, dann kann man sich wirklich auf vielleicht mannschaftstaktische Muster und essenzielle Aspekte, ich nenne es mal beschränken. Wenn es jetzt aber darum geht, für einen Verein oder in einem Verein das Ganze zu machen, dann braucht man definitiv mehr als eine Stunde, weil man dann vom großen Ganzen eigentlich immer tiefer geht und dann kann das Ganze natürlich auch mal zwei Stunden oder zweieinhalb Stunden dauern, ganz klar.
Und was ist dann der von dir angesprochene Workflow? Wie gehst du sowas an? Du kommst morgens ins Büro, denkst du, okay, gut, jetzt bereite ich mal Rea Madrid vor. Wir gehen mal von dem Fall aus, dass es nicht für die Medien vorbereitet ist, sondern tatsächlich, als würdest du Carlos Ancelotti dann die Mappe rüber schieben, würdest du sagen, so, Carlos, das sind die Sachen, auf die muss ich einstellen. Du wusstest es bestimmt noch nicht, aber ich habe es dir aufgeschrieben. Wie würdest du dann vorgehen? Kader ausdrücken, VHS-Kassettin an 5 Zeichen einschmeißen und los geht's, oder?
Mehr oder weniger. Ich brauche natürlich erstmal Videomaterial, das ist ganz klar.
Ist das schwierig heutzutage noch?
Also das Videomaterial gibt es, aber du musst es halt besorgen. Und das kostet halt dann auch mal Geld. Und dann ist es natürlich mit dem Internet heutzutage so, dass man sehr viele gute Informationen auch schon im Internet rausziehen kann, was dann natürlich auch sämtliche Kader etc. betrifft. Wenn ich es jetzt für Herrn Angelotti machen würde, dann wäre es so, dass ich natürlich noch sehr viele Infomappen beziehen könnte, auch rein statistischer Natur von Anbietern, wie zum Beispiel auch Opta, sodass ich da schon sehr viele Informationen kriegen würde, die ich selber nicht mehr zwangsläufig recherchieren müsste.
Und das würdest du dir vor dem Spiel angucken, die Spielstatistiken zu dem Spiel?
Das ist, denke ich, unterschiedlich. Manchmal kann man sich das Ganze vorher schon durchlesen, um einen Eindruck zu gewinnen. Manchmal nachher, um vielleicht seine Eindrücke zu bestätigen. Manchmal ist es eine Erkenntnis vielleicht, die im Spiel läuft, die man vielleicht mal kurz nachschauen möchte, was denn die Daten dazu sagen. Vorausgesetzt, es gibt eine Aussage dazu, das gibt es ja auch nicht immer. Und deswegen glaube ich, gibt es da kein Patentrezept.
Und dann nimmst du dir dein Blog oder dein Notizprogramm und fängst an, die Muster zu erkennen, die nicht jeder sieht.
Ich gehe es so an, dass wir eine Videoanalyse Software haben, in der ich dann das Video einspeise, wenn man so will. Und dann habe ich die Möglichkeit, in dieser Software verschiedene Tags zu setzen. Das kann man sich vorstellen wie in and out. Es kommt eine Situation, eine Spieleröffnung und ich sage, das interessiert mich jetzt. Dann klicke ich das Ganze an und dann beginnt die Situation zu laufen. Dann sage ich irgendwann wieder Stopp und dann ist das Thema wieder erledigt. Dann habe ich diese Sequenz-Spieleröffnung zum Beispiel. Und so kann ich das ganze Spiel durchsequenzen, wenn man so will. Und kann das Ganze nach dem Muster oder nach der Methode, wie ich es für mich persönlich als sinnvoll sehe, kann ich es durchtaggen und reduziere dadurch eigentlich das Spiel auf die elementaren Bausteine. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansätze, was alles dann getaggt wird sozusagen. Ich glaube aber, dass im Grunde jeder übergreifend dieselben hat. Es kommt nur darauf an, wie tief man dann reingeht. Das ist, wie wir vorher gesagt haben, Spiel gegen den Ball und Spiel mit dem Ball die Unterscheidung. Im Spiel gegen den Ball ist es das Anlaufverhalten der Mannschaft, wenn die eben nicht den Ball haben. Es ist die Pressing-Art in dem Zusammenhang. Es ist das Umschalten eben nach Ballverlust. Was passiert dann? Es sind defensive Einzelspieler-Auffälligkeiten. Es sind defensive Standard-Situationen, die haben wir bisher noch gar nicht angesprochen. Die spielen aber natürlich auch eine Rolle, ist klar. Und im Spiel mit dem Ball genau dasselbe, wie vorher die Struktur eigentlich schonmal kurz angesprochen. Also wie wird das Spiel eröffnet? Spieleröffnung heißt, über Spielen eigentlich der ersten Verteidigungsreihe des Gegners, wenn man so will. Und wie wird das Spiel fortgesetzt? Wie ist das Umschalten nach Ballgewinn? Also gibt es hier auch Muster, die zu erkennen sind. Viele Mannschaften haben verschiedene Entwicklungsspieler zum Beispiel, die sich sehr stark immer dann im Zentrum positionieren und schon auf Lücke eigentlich stehen. Wenn der Ball gewonnen wird, dass man eigentlich direkt auf die Person umschalten kann. Dann gibt es Zielspiele, um es jetzt vielleicht mal an dem Beispiel Dortmund festzumachen. Ich glaube, das letzte Saison war auch gegen die Bayern sehr stark. Ich glaube, es war Kagawa.
Ja, das war das Rückspiel. Nein, das Spiel in München war das.
Nein, das war das Spiel in Dortmund, glaube ich.
Stimmt, mit Gündüren verwechselt, wo er ihn vorgeschoben hat von der 6. Das war das Spiel in München und du redest vom Dortmunderspiel.
Genau. Pokalfinale war er dann auch noch. Ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher, wer der Entwicklungsspieler war, aber einfach eine Person, die sich dann im Zentrum schon so ein Stück weit positioniert. Und dann hat man zum Beispiel im Umschalten bei Dortmund jemanden wie Aubameyang, der natürlich absoluter Zielspieler ist, der sofort in die Tiefe geschickt wird gerne, wenn es möglich ist, der natürlich dazu auch unfassbar geile Laufwege hat. Und so kann man eben auch das Umschalten nach Ballgewinnen ein bisschen strukturieren. Das Gesamte ergibt dann eigentlich einen Ausschnitt eines Spiels, wenn man so will. Und dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, diese Tags, die man dann hatte, entsprechend zu einem Video zusammenzuschneiden. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, in dieser Software, in dem Fall ist es Dartfish, mit denen wir arbeiten, nenne ich jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz, weil ich sie sehr gut finde, kann man dann eben auch Dinge visualisieren, Spieler hervorheben zum Beispiel, freie Räume oder Ähnliches dann auch skizzieren, also einfach um klar zu machen, hey, das ist das Muster bei der Mannschaft. Und dann ist natürlich immer noch die Frage, wie landet das beim Trainer? Und da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten auch. Also ich kann natürlich ganz banal mir das als Videodatei abspeichern und als USB-Stick oder so übergeben. Ist aber, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr so zeitgemäß. Heutzutage hat man ja auch die Möglichkeit, das alles online zu machen. Und da gibt es dann zum Beispiel auch von dem Anbieter eine Video-Plattform, wo man dann auch von überall drauf zugreifen kann und das Ganze auch sehr interaktiv gestalten kann.
Wie schwierig ist es denn da, sich nicht im Detail zu verlieren? Ich stelle mir die schwierigste Aufgabe eigentlich gar nicht darin vor, Muster zu erkennen oder auch die verschiedenen Spielsituationen. Wahrscheinlich könnte ich das mit dem Vertaggen auch halbwegs hinbekommen. Aber dann irgendwann kommt der schmerzhafte Punkt, wo du dich entscheiden musst. Auf was reduziere ich es jetzt? Wie schafft man es da, Dinge nicht überzubewerten oder sich nicht so sehr im Detail zu verlieren? Vielleicht auch Dinge einzuberechnen, wie – da hatten sie irgendwie aber auch einen komischen Tag. Die beiden anderen Spieler haben mir andere Dinge gezeigt. Ist das dann Erfahrung? Ist das Intuition?
Also ich glaube, zunächst einmal ist es so, dass man insgesamt Spielanalyse auch nicht überbewerten sollte. Ich glaube, es gibt so einen Spruch, den ich ganz cool finde und habe ich beim DFB mal gelernt. Es gibt auch Trainer, die können den Erfolg der Mannschaft nicht verhindern. Okay, das ist ein guter Spruch. Ich weiß, ich schieße mir jetzt ins eigene Knie, aber wir wissen nicht, welchen Anteil hat die Spielanalyse, egal wie umfassend sie betrieben wird, und auch eine Spielphilosophie auf den Erfolg. Das will ich einfach mal im Grunde hier reinschmeißen, weil der Hype schon so durchaus stark ist in der letzten Zeit, dass Spielanalyse nicht über Sieg oder Niederlage entscheidet. Man hat aber die Möglichkeit, die Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit zu erhöhen. Das ist jetzt nichts wissenschaftlich Nachgewiesenes, aber das ist eine These von meiner Seite, basierend auf den Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe. In der Reduktion des Ganzen ist es elementar, dass man Kernaussagen hinkriegt, die für den Trainer ins Training eingebaut werden können, die bei der Mannschaft ankommen und die einfach wirklich einen klaren Matchplan darstellen, dass jeder weiß, was er zu tun hat. Auch da ist es dann, glaube ich, sehr mannschaftsabhängig, wie viel Information ich jedem Einzelnen gebe. Dann bin ich wieder auch beim Chef-Trainer, der, glaube ich, eine elementare Rolle spielt, der auch vielleicht so ein Stück weit entscheiden muss, wie viel baue ich jetzt auch in die Mannschaftsanalyse ein, wie viel Info gebe ich auch so einem Spieler im Eins-zu-eins-Gespräch oder in der Gruppenanalyse zum Beispiel. Ein Patentrezept, glaube ich, gibt es nicht, aber Fakt ist, man muss es in jedem Fall auch reduzieren. Und das ist vielleicht, wenn ich das noch anführen darf, das ist auch die Schwierigkeit, finde ich. Also da kann ich jetzt auch nur so aus meiner persönlichen Erfahrung sprechen. Das ist auch die Schwierigkeit, wenn man mit so einem Spiel anfängt. Also jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die man nicht kennt. Wenn wir jetzt Bundesligamannschaft anschauen, dann haben wir schon ungefähr eine Idee im Kopf, wie die spielen. Wir kennen die Spieler so ein bisschen. Jetzt spielt er aber dann zum Beispiel Dortmund in zwei Wochen in Warschau. Die Dortmunder kennen natürlich Warschau ganz bestimmt, haben sie schon oft gesehen. Aber wir gehen jetzt mal von dem Fall aus, wir kennen die Mannschaft nicht. Dann fangen die an, sich mit einem gewissen Spielzug vorzukombinieren. Wir denken, das muss ein Muster sein, aber wir sehen das Ganze nicht nochmal. War das jetzt ein Einzelfall oder wird es noch zum Muster?
Da muss man dann mehr Spiele sehen.
Richtig, da muss man dann wiederum mehr Spiele sehen. Da sind wir wieder bei vorher. Dieser Durchschnitt ist schwierig. Die Bundesliga untereinander kennt sich natürlich auch sehr gut. Die wissen ungefähr auch, wie der Gegner agiert und schaut sich dann nochmal Dinge an. Und dann kommen die auf ein gutes Ergebnis. Mannschaften, die unbekannt sind, sind da einfach deutlich schwieriger.
Für die Schlusskonferenz, in der ich über den Bundesligaspieltag spreche mit meinen Gästen, schaue ich mir ja auch die fünf Livespiele, die man angucken kann als normaler Fan, der sich nichts aufnimmt, die sehe ich immer über die volle Länge normalerweise. Und bei allen anderen gucke ich dann manchmal nehme ich mir auch noch was auf und schaue mir das dann auch noch nachts an, je nach Zeitmanagement auch. Und es kommt immer wieder vor, dass ich Spiele sehe und aber einigermaßen erkenntnislos da rausgehe. Und dann weiß ich manchmal nicht, liegt das jetzt an meiner Tagesform? Man hat auch manchmal auch einfach einen schlechten Tag oder man wusste halt schon, dass das ein 0-0 ist und ist dann vielleicht schon mit irgendwie dover Laune da reingegangen. Ist das bei dir auch manchmal so, dass du sagst, gut, schön, dass ich mir jetzt dieses Spiel hier in kondensierter Art und Weise noch mal reingezogen habe, aber eigentlich habe ich daraus nicht gelernt?
Ja, zu 100 Prozent. Okay, das tröstet mich. Ich kann da jetzt auch wiederum nur für mich sprechen, ich weiß nicht, wie es den Kollegen geht. Das kommt schon mal vor, dass dann einfach keine großen Erkenntnisse zu sehen sind. Und man halt dann wirklich aber trotzdem diese reduzierten Erkenntnisse irgendwo mitnimmt. Und selbst die geben einem eine Information. Und was man natürlich auch immer ganz gut machen kann, vielleicht auch ein Tipp irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt eine Mannschaft analysiere und ich finde einfach nicht dieses Muster, ich finde nicht das, was sie ausmacht oder so, dann kann man schon versuchen, auch sehr stark über die Einzelspieler zu kommen. Also welche Rollen haben auch die Einzelspieler in diesem System? Also was ist auffällig, wie sie sich mit dem Ball oder gegen den Ball bewegen, wo vielleicht dadurch auch Räume entstehen oder ähnliches. Und das ist eine Ebene, die man da immer ganz gut auch anschauen kann, um vielleicht auch noch Erkenntnisse, die interessant sind, mitzunehmen.
Welche Rolle spielen da für dich Statistiken?
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich stehe Statistiken insgesamt schon relativ kritisch gegenüber. Auch wenn ich mich zuletzt sehr intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt habe. Ich glaube, dass wir uns auch da aktuell in einer Wandlung befinden. Ich glaube, dass wir eine lange Zeit – es ist noch gar nicht so lange her – da kamen dann unglaublich viele Statistiken und dann war es erstmal so, wow, Buff, was können wir jetzt alles über diesen Fußball wissen? Und irgendwie alle haben damit gearbeitet und viel läuft auch medial ab, was Statistiken betrifft, weil da kann man immer natürlich schöne Fakten hinklatschen und auch mal eine Schlagzeile bilden.
Es wirkt auch immer wahnsinnig gebildet. Also allein, wenn du die Torschüsse zitiert hast eines Spiels, dann habe ich immer den Eindruck, dass das manche auch so ein bisschen als das Abzeichen verwenden, um zu sagen, hier guck mal, wie ich mich mit diesem Spiel beschäftigt habe.
Ja, klar, kommt auch noch mit dazu. Aber es ist halt, und da bin ich bei meinem Anfangspunkt von der Doktorarbeit eigentlich, es hat zunächst nichts oder nur wenig oft was direkt mit dem Trainingsplatz zu tun. Also das, was ich als Mehrwert gewinnen kann aus den Daten. Ich habe ein doofes Beispiel auch, das erzähle ich gerne immer wieder, weil ich es aber auch so sauwitzig finde, ist, es spielte Team A gegen Team B und Team A bezwang Team B mit 5 zu 0. Und dann wurde der Experte Y, vielleicht war es auch der Trainer, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, zumindest würde ich es auch nicht verraten, wurde dann nach dem Spiel gefragt, warum ist denn dieses Spiel jetzt 5 zu 0 ausgegangen. Und dann Blick auf die Daten und dann hieß es, naja, ist doch klar, die sind im Schnitt halt auch 6 Kilometer mehr gelaufen oder 4 oder was weiß ich. Und dann hat man sich aber die Daten ein bisschen genauer angeschaut und Ende vom Lied war, dass die Tore oder dass die nach den Toren eigentlich immer zum Jubeln zu den Fans gelaufen sind, die halt in dem Fall auf der anderen Seite vom Stadion waren, da natürlich relativ viel gelaufene Meter entstanden sind. Und das ist halt so ein Kernbeispiel davon, wie man halt Daten natürlich nicht einsetzen darf, indem man sie einfach fehl interpretieren kann. Und das ist so die Gefahr des Ganzen.
Aber dann kann ich mich ja nie auf Daten verlassen, weil ich habe ja auch nicht die Zeit, das Spiel so oft und mit so vielen Augen quasi anzugucken, dass ich mir immer sicher sein kann, dass da jetzt kein Fehler oder keine Missinterpretation drin liegt. Die Daten sind ja nicht falsch. Muss ich mich nicht ab einem gewissen Punkt auch manchmal auf Daten verlassen können?
Absolut. Und das kann man heutzutage auch. Also die Daten werden ja sehr gut erhoben auch und die Daten entwickeln sich ja weiter. Ich will bloß damit sagen, man muss einfach vorsichtig sein, wie man die Daten interpretiert und einsetzt. Und in dem Fall konnte man sie halt einfach nicht als schlüssiges Argument verwenden. Und die Entwicklung zeigt eben, dass dann viele fanden es dann immer super und klasse, mit diesen Daten zu arbeiten. Und irgendwann hatte man aber so viel Daten, dass man irgendwann mal sich überlegt hat, hey, okay, und was kann ich jetzt eigentlich damit anfangen? In der Fußballforschung sozusagen war es dann oft so, dass man versucht hat, Zusammenhänge zu suchen. Also ich schmeiße in irgendeine Maschine alle Daten rein und dann schaue ich mal, was hinten rauskommt. Zum Beispiel. Und dann kommt von mir aus raus, naja, ich gewinne mehr Spiele, wenn ich mehr Flanken schlage. Jetzt bin ich aber als Spielanalyst im Verein und dann gehe ich zu meinem Trainer und sage, hey, wir gewinnen mehr Spiele, wenn wir mehr Flanken schlagen. Dann sagt er zu mir, hol dir deinen Vertrag ab. Die Information kann ich nicht gebrauchen, sozusagen.
Aber das ist doch dieser Ansatz, den zum Beispiel so ein Club wie North Joland in Dänemark, glaube ich, ist es verfolgt und was ja so ein bisschen aus dem Baseball rüber kam. Ich habe gerade – Moneyball heißt glaube ich der Film mit Brad Pitt – mit dem – ach Gott, jetzt habe ich gerade den Teamnamen vergessen – auf jeden Fall ein Baseball-Team, das sehr nach Statistiken dann gescoutet hat und so dann sportlichen Erfolg hatte. Und das ist inzwischen ja auch bei manchen Teams im Fußball gelandet, wobei man schon mal die Einschränkung machen muss, Baseball ist ein noch viel krass datenbasierterer Sport als Fußball. Aber dennoch gibt es ja diese Ansätze.
Ja, absolut. Und ich will diese Ansätze auch gar nicht schlechtreden. Das ist nur nicht mein persönlicher Ansatz. Und für mich sind diese Vereine dann wie Mütiland, glaube ich, heißt auch einer, so ein bisschen eine Blackbox. Weil man kriegt sie aktuell auch nur so ein Stück weit von außen mit. Wie viel dann irgendwie mit den Statistiken gemacht wird, was genau gemacht wird, ist ja noch so ein bisschen Blackbox, würde ich jetzt behaupten.
Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Beispiel gelesen, wo die Flanke gegenüber dem vertikalen Pass in den Strafraum gestellt wurde. Das ist ein bisschen schief, weil nicht immer, wenn du in der Flankenposition bist, bist du auch in der Position, vertikalen Pass zu spielen. Aber immerhin könntest du einen Pass in den Strafraum spielen. Wo eben rauskam, allein vom Statistischen her gesehen, ist es immer schlau, auf die Flanke zu verzichten und versuchen, den vertikalen Pass zu spielen. Weil der in einem von zehn Fällen zum Tor führt und die Flanke eben in weniger Fällen. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, naja, das ist schon eine Erkenntnis. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt eine Mannschaft habe, wo vorne ein 2, 50 Meter Stürmer drin steht, der nicht dribbeln kann, dann hilft mir diese Erkenntnis nicht weiter, ich werde bei Flanken bleiben. Aber das ist doch schon etwas, wo man sagen kann, das ist durchaus eine interessante Erkenntnis. Weil vielleicht legt das ja auch größere Muster global gesehen im Fußball auf. Dadurch, dass Mannschaften relativ ähnlich verteidigen. Das Zentrum ist jetzt bei allen Mannschaften dicht. Das hat man auch bei der Europameisterschaft super gesehen. Alle Mannschaften können das inzwischen. Manche können es, indem sie da drei Defensive hinstellen. Manche schaffen es aber auch sogar nur mit einem Defensiven. Aber das Zentrum, der Bereich 20 Meter vorm Tor zentral, der ist relativ dicht. Und deswegen passiert viel über die Flügel. Und sowas könnten doch auch solche Big-Data-Analysen da so einem Hinweise drauf geben, was quasi die Mittel sind, auf die Mannschaften weniger gut vorbereitet sind vielleicht.
Ja, ein langgezogenes Ja. Ich glaube, du hast ja jetzt schon Beispiele genannt, die ja eigentlich schon sehr stark in die fußballspezifischere Richtung gehen. Also die schon auch eingesetzt werden, um Fragen zu beantworten, die die Praxis interessieren. Das ist ja schon mal der richtige Ansatz, finde ich. Das hatten wir eine lange Zeit nicht, und jetzt haben wir es aber. Oder jetzt bewegen wir uns Schritt für Schritt dahin. Jetzt habe ich so quasi meinen historischen Abschnitt von vorher damit beendet. Ich glaube, aber trotzdem, und du hast das Beispiel ja auch selber genannt, dass du es nicht verallgemeinern kannst. Also diese verallgemeinerte Aussage, 9 von 10 oder von mir aus 99 von 100 oder wie auch immer, ist halt unglaublich schwierig jetzt auch für mich verwertbar als Trainer einer Mannschaft. Wenn du es mir jetzt vielleicht bezogen auf meine Mannschaft sagst, und bei uns war das so und so oft, in so und so vielen Fällen war das dann so und so, dann hat es denke ich eine größere Bedeutung auch. Aber dann beziehst du schon auf deine eigene Mannschaft. Und dann bist du so in dem Konstrukt auch oder in so einem Feld, dass der Analyst in einem Verein auch bearbeiten kann, sollte, wie auch immer, dass er diese Daten, die er zur Verfügung hat, dass er die spezifisch auf die eigene Mannschaft auch wirklich einsetzt. Und das ist glaube ich so ein Weg, der richtig ist. Ich nenne dir aber mal ein anderes Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt wieder bei diesen Mustern sind. Im Grunde geht es darum, einen Matchplan zu erstellen. Und wenn jetzt eine Mannschaft läuft auf eine gewisse Art und Weise an, dann kann ich das Spiel auf eine gewisse Art und Weise eröffnen, um diese erste Verteidigungslinie beispielsweise zu überspielen. Jetzt kann ich da sagen, wir spielen immer über unseren linken Außenverteidiger, weil den ihr rechter äußerer Mittelfeldspieler zum Beispiel, der steht immer viel zu breit. Und dann können wir von da den Pass ins Zentrum spielen. Und dann bin ich einen Schritt weiter, was das Spiel betrifft. Die Frage ist, welche Daten geben mir diese Informationen?
Ja gut, dafür muss man es gesehen haben, das stimmt schon.
Das ist halt so die Gradwanderung, wie ich da Daten einsetze. Ich persönlich finde – und wir haben ein sehr großes Projekt für die Deutsche Fußballliga da auch umgesetzt – wir haben versucht, das Blatt umzudrehen und nicht die Daten als Grundlage zu nehmen und zu sehen, was kann ich aus den Daten ziehen, sondern wirklich erstmal die Frage zu stellen, was will ich in der Praxis, was will ich als Trainer zum Beispiel, denn eigentlich wissen? Und was ich wissen will, sind die Dinge, die wir jetzt schon mehrmals genannt haben. Diese Unterkategorien, wenn man so will, im Spiel mit dem Ball und im Spiel gegen den Spiel, Eröffnungen etc. Und was wir gemacht haben, ist diese Daten als Grundlage zu nehmen. Also wir haben die Möglichkeit gehabt, Positions- und Ereignisdaten, die es in der Bundesliga gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Begrifflichkeiten…
Erklärst du mal kurz für die Hörer.
Gerne. Also Positionsdaten, wie der Name schon sagt, sind die Positionen der Spieler und des Balles. Das wird mehrmals pro Sekunde festgehalten, sodass ich immer eigentlich weiß, wo der Spieler ist. Und so entstehen dann z.B. auch sogenannte Heatmaps, die man ja so kennt. Und Event- oder Ereignisdaten sind dann eben Aktionen, Schüsse, Pässe, Tacklings usw. Und im Grunde wird natürlich versucht, rein aus diesen Positions- und Ereignisdaten Informationen rauszuziehen. Und wir haben gesagt, okay, wir wollen z.B. wissen, mit welchem Angriffsverhalten versucht denn eine Mannschaft Torschancen zu erspielen. Und haben gesagt, okay, was für Angriffsverhalten gibt es denn z.B.? Es gibt so das klassische Ballbesitzspiel, Beispiel FC Bayern, wo man aus den Positionen heraus viele Pässe, geringer Raumgewinn gegen eine geordnete Defensive. Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, den Schnellangriff des Spiels in die Tiefe zu bevorzugen. Das heißt z.B. von hinten wirklich immer den langen Ball zu spielen, dann vielleicht auf den zweiten Ball zu gehen. Das heißt, du spielst wenige Pässe, erst aber einen sehr hohen Raumgewinn. Und dann gibt es auch das klassische Konterspiel, wo du sagst, du stehst halt tief und versuchst, den Ball zu erobern und dann ab die Post. Das sind so drei Verhaltensweisen, die vieles schon mal abbilden. Wir haben es beispielsweise in dem Projekt geschafft, dass wir mit diesen Daten dieses Angriffsverhalten in einem Spiel extrahieren können. Dass wir im Nachhinein sagen können, also, ihr habt so und so viele Positionsangriffe gespielt, so und so viele Konterangriffe gespielt und wir sind sogar prinzipiell in der Lage, die Videosequenzen dann auch auszuspucken, dass du dir als Analyst gar nicht mehr prinzipiell das ganze Spiel anschauen müsstest, sondern du könntest dir einfach alle Positionsangriffe anschauen und hättest dadurch auch natürlich die Spieleröffnung usw. usf. Und das finde ich einen Ansatz, der total spannend ist, auch im Einsatz der Daten.
Okay, das heißt quasi aus den Daten dann gleich was rausgezogen. Ich stehe ja immer – also ich schaue mir logischerweise auch in der Vorbereitung der Sendung immer alle Statistiken zu den Spielen an, aber zitiere auch nur die, die ich tatsächlich für relevant halte. Also wenn die Statistik entweder mich bestätigt neben dem, was ich gesehen habe, oder aber auch wenn die Statistik mich widerlegt war, dann könnte es auch sein, dass ich vielleicht etwas falsch beobachtet habe. Aber was ich grundsätzlich immer viel, viel wertvoller finde als die reinen Zahlen, ist alles, was auf dem Spielfeld dargestellt wird. Also die berühmten Pfeilgrafiken, in denen ich sehen kann, lange Bälle, welche davon erfolgreich waren, da kann man so oft Muster kennen. Oder ich mag auch einfach mir anzugucken, wie ist die Ballverteilung der Ballkontakte von einzelnen Spielern. Das ist im Grunde ein bisschen wie eine Heatmap, aber schon auch ein bisschen anders. Also bei Darmstadt sah es immer total lustig aus, weil die Außen immer die Seitenlinie noch mal quasi fetter gemalt haben, weil die halt einfach nur auf den Flügeln geschickt wurden im Eröffnungsspiel. Ich finde, dass es über den rein zahlen Aspekt hin helfen mir persönlich diese Daten mehr. Zumindest so von meinem persönlichen Gefühl her. Aber gleichzeitig würde ich sagen, dass es eine Art und Weise auf ein Fußballspiel zu gucken, auch retrospektiv, die schon sehr sophisticated ist und schon sehr akademisch auch. Die Medien haben doch eigentlich gar nicht die Chance, sowas einzusetzen, zumindest nicht in der direkten Nachberichterstattung. Da ist es doch eigentlich logisch, dass man bei so etwas wie Torschussverhältnis stehen bleibt. Oder würdest du dir was anderes wünschen?
Ja, das kommt jetzt im Grunde darauf an, wie viel Zeit habe ich zur Verfügung und wie knapp ist es nach dem Spiel. Wobei die Daten ja live reinlaufen. Also die Daten sind abrufbar. Ich glaube auch, um vielleicht für die Daten nochmal zu sprechen, ich schaue mir auch bei jedem Spiel, wenn ich Daten habe, schaue ich sie mir auch an. Also ich will es nicht komplett verwerfen. Ich finde, dass es in der Spielanalyse elementar ist, sie hinzuzufügen und sie zu haben auch und Infos herauszuziehen. Vor allem, wie du sagst, wenn man es dann mit Pfeilen in Verbindungen bringen kann, wo man dann eben wieder Muster rauslesen kann. Und das ist aber der Ansatz, den ich dann entscheiden finde. Ich glaube, was die Berichterstattung betrifft, würde ich mir sowieso wünschen, dass wir insgesamt noch ein bisschen detaillierter arbeiten. Also auch zum Beispiel Dinge mit einbeziehen oder vielleicht auch mal Fragen an Trainer stellen, die auch taktisch wirklich in der Tiefe sind. Also ich habe es zum Beispiel bei Pep Guardiola erlebt. Wenn man dem in Spanien eine Frage gestellt hat, die einen taktischen Hintergrund hatte, wo er wirklich gemerkt hat, wow, der hat sich damit jetzt intensiv auseinandergesetzt und der will von mir eine ernsthafte Aussage dazu haben, dann hat er leuchtende Augen gekriegt und hat diese Frage beantwortet. Und ich glaube, dass das etwas ist, was wir tatsächlich vielleicht noch so ein Stück weit optimieren können.
Ja, man hat den Eindruck bekommen, dass das einer der Gründe war, warum er nicht ganz so glücklich immer war, wenn er mit Medienvertretern sprechen musste. Das war, glaube ich, einer der Aspekte, dass er sich zu oft auf die Frage reduziert hat, warum haben sie die Champions League noch nicht gewonnen und zu wenig vielleicht um solche Dinge ging. Und jetzt hast du ja vorhin aber auch schon richtigerweise gesagt, Spielanalyse darf man auch nicht überbewerten. Wie analysiert man denn eigentlich den Faktor Zufall, der ja eigentlich vielleicht gerade weil so viele Mannschaften gelernt haben zu verteidigen, gerade eine größere Rolle spielt denn je? Ich bin mir da mal so gar nicht sicher.
Also in der Forschung wurde der Faktor Zufall immer wieder auch analysiert und so weiter und so fort. Möchte ich aber gar nicht darauf eingehen. Ich habe Frank Wormuth, den Leiter der Fußballlehrerausbildung auf einem Kongress mal gehört. Er meinte, im Fußball gibt es keinen Zufall.
Okay, interessant.
Das fand ich einen ganz interessanten Ansatz. Ich glaube, dass man…
Aber das ist doch ein bisschen zu krass, oder? Das kann ich doch nicht sagen. Also wenn jemand über den Ball haut, dann hat das doch… Das ist doch Zufall.
Ja, oder es ist ein technischer…
Er war falsch zum Beigesstand.
technischer Mangel, ja. Also, es ist ein Ansatz. Ich finde ihn nicht uninteressant. Ich glaube, dass man den Zufall erstmal so hinnehmen muss, wie er ist im Fußball. Und man kann ihn sicher teilweise auch zur Nutze machen. Also es gibt ja Herangehensweisen. Eine Zeit lang hat es Leverkusen auch echt perfektioniert, die immer wieder auf den zweiten Ball gespielt haben. Also da war dann Kiesling ganz vorne mit dabei und dann wurde halt auch ein langer Ball auf Kiesling geplant gespielt. Und Kiesling hatte dann mehrere Optionen. Er konnte den Ball halten, die anderen konnten nachrücken oder er konnte ihn ablegen. Dann war alles wunderbar, weil dann war ich in einer guten Position. Oder es war halt so, dass der Zweikampf nicht gewonnen wurde. Und dann wurde aber sehr stark versucht, über so ein provoziertes Gegenpressing den Ball direkt wieder zu erobern. Und in dieser Unordnung, sind wir wieder bei dem Thema, spielt Zufall eine riesen Rolle. Wie du sagst, dann springt halt der Ball vom rechten Bein ans linke, vom anderen und so und plötzlich bin ich aber in Ballbesitz. Ich habe aber diesen Zufall vorher provoziert. Und deswegen kann man das schon durchaus sich zu Nutze machen auf der einen Seite. Man kann aber auch versuchen, den Zufall bestmöglich zu minimieren, indem ich halt, so wie die Bayern zum Beispiel, eine mega Spielkontrolle habe.
Wobei sie auch sehr vom Zufall auch profitieren. Ich habe jetzt gestern tatsächlich nochmal das Spiel gegen Juve gesehen, das Rückspiel, mit dem 1 zu 2 und 2 zu 2 in 75. und 90 plus 2. Minute. Und beide Flanken, die zu den Toren geführt haben, einmal Lewandowski, einmal Müller, waren quasi nach einem Ballverlust, denen sie dann schnell den Ball zurück gewonnen. Und dann war Juve zweimal nicht richtig geordnet. Einmal war es so, dass sie nicht schnell genug rausgerückt haben, und Costa konnte dann eine wunderbare Flank geschlagen. Das war dann in dem Moment, wo er in der Luft war, nicht mehr zu verteidigen, der Ball. Und das andere Mal war es dann Pass nach außen und dann die Flanke an den zweiten Pfosten. Da ist dann noch ein zweiter Fehler passiert. Aber jetzt verliere ich mich in Details.
Aber jetzt stelle ich dir mal eine Frage. Was genau davon war jetzt der Zufall?
Der erste Ballverlust.
Das Gegner.
Nein, Bayern hat quasi im Offensivspiel den Ball verloren. Und dann haben sie ihn aber gleich wieder zurück gewonnen. Und ich würde sagen, der Ballverlust ist der Zufall. Das Zurückgewinnen kommt aus ihrer Ordnung heraus und aus dem Gegenpressing, was Pep eben beigebracht hat. Oder willst du mir jetzt sagen, sie haben absichtlich den Ball verloren? Das gibt es ja auch manchmal, dass man sagt, manche, es würden bewusst Fehlpässe gespielt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe das noch nie gesehen, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, oh, dieser Fehlpass, der war jetzt aber extra gespielt.
Ja, doch. Ich habe es schon mal gesehen. Zumindest habe ich es mir eingebildet. Aber ich meine, wenn wir über sowas diskutieren, dann sind wir fast schon auf einer spirituellen Ebene. Weil wer entscheidet denn, dass jetzt der Ball da verloren geht oder nicht? Ja, wie auch immer er heißt. Ob es der Fußballgott ist oder wer auch immer es ist. Ich meine, es gibt Dinge, die können wir nicht kontrollieren. Und ob wir es dann Zufall taufen oder wie auch immer, sei dahingestellt. Ich glaube, das Elementare in dem Fall ist halt nur, den Zufall sich in dem Fall wieder zunutze zu machen und dann halt direkt wieder in den Zweikampf zu kommen. Wieder ins Gegenpressing zu gehen und den Ball in einer guten Position wiederzuholen. Ich glaube, da kommen wir, was den Zufall betrifft, in eine Diskussion, die beim Fußball irgendwo anfängt und aufhört irgendwo bei grundsätzlichen Dingen, die uns im Sinn des Lebens beschäftigen.
Ja, ich verstehe deinen Ansatz und stimme den auch in Teilen zu. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, es gibt ja diese Spiele, die so vollkommen merkwürdig laufen, wo man ohne Erkenntnisgewinn rausgeht. Manchmal kann man auch gar nicht im Nachhinein sagen, warum hätte die Mannschaft gewonnen. Man ist so ein bisschen ratlos. Manchmal fehlt es nicht, dass man einfach zugesteht. Rein mit analytischen Aspekten ist das jetzt nicht zu erklären. Es gibt ja auch z.B. Taktik-Blocks, die sehr genau jedes Spiel sezieren. Da denke ich mir manchmal, sorry Jungs, aber zu dem Match hättet ihr jetzt eigentlich schreiben müssen. Die Sachen sind uns aufgefallen, aber so ganz hat es nicht ganz mit dem zu tun gehabt, was rausgekommen ist. Es gibt ja noch die Faktoren Tagesform, Stand der Sonne, Gegenwind, von der Freundin getrennt.
Was hab ich gegessen? Wie hab ich geschlafen?
Genau.
Absolut. Das ist das, was ich eingangs meinte, wo ich gesagt habe, man muss vorsichtig sein, dass man die Spielanalyse nicht auf irgendeinen Sockel stellt, auf der sie tatsächlich eben nicht ist. Ich glaube, man muss unterscheiden. Zum einen ist es so, und da bin ich beim Thema Muster, dass man diese Muster findet und so und klar und dann stellen wir uns auf die Mannschaft ein und dann versuchen wir, denen ihre Stärken zu schwächen und denen ihre Schwächen zu unseren Stärken zu machen. So, einfach gesprochen. Wie es dann zu Toren und Torschancen kommt, steht nochmal auf einem völlig anderen Blatt. Da geb ich dir zu 100 Prozent Recht und da gibt's Spiele, das kannst du dann vorab nicht analysieren. Und da bin ich wieder bei dem Thema Perturbationen. Die Ursachen zu finden, warum es zu einer Gleichgewichtsstörung kommt, sozusagen. Das ist oftmals völlig fern von dem, was man vielleicht dann vorab analysiert hat und hat auch dann oftmals vielleicht mit dem Fußball zu tun. Das steht völlig außer Frage. Deswegen ist auch die Spielanalyse, die Taktik, ist ein Mosaikbaustein, der ein Stück weit die gesamte Leistungsfähigkeit ausmacht. Zur Leistungsfähigkeit an dem Tag, speziell von einer Mannschaft, gehören tatsächlich noch viele, viele andere Dinge dazu. Aber auch die kann ich nicht alle kontrollieren. Das sich der jetzt von der Freundin trennt, das werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht verhindern können.
Das könnte auch sein, dass es sie stärker macht, je nachdem, wie es gelaufen ist. Man kann es aber nicht sagen. Dann lass mal, weil wir jetzt wieder in den selben Themenbereich reingerutschen, dann lass mal bei dem bleiben, wo man sagen kann, das kann man sehr gut analysieren. Ich würde mit dir gerne über Standard-Situationen im Fußball sprechen. Das ist tatsächlich auch eins der großen Mirakele, was ich immer auf der Stirn habe. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt auch emotional dem FC Bayern sehr nahe und es tut mir im Herz weh, Ecken der Bayern zu sehen. Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt besser wird mit Mats Hummels, dass man da vielleicht mal wieder ein paar an den kurzen Pfosten spielt und das ist dann schwierig zu verteidigen. So hat man ja auch mal die Champions League verloren. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, bis auf die Unterscheidung, ob man da mit Raum oder mit Mannendeckung spielt, oder viele spielen mit einer Mischform. Das heißt, ich nehme die gefährlichsten Gegenspieler in die Mannendeckung und die restlichen Verteidiger von meiner Mannschaft stehen im Raum, weil es auch besser ist für die Spieleröffnung, wenn man den Ball gewinnt. Aber davon abgesehen habe ich den Eindruck, es tut sich auf diesem Gebiet nichts. Warum ist das denn so? Denn das ist doch das Einzige, was ich immer wieder unter fast laborhaften Bedingungen trainieren kann.
Ja, ich kann es aber sowohl trainieren, dass ich ein Tor erziele, aber ich kann es auch laborhaft trainieren, dass ich es verhindern kann.
Okay, deswegen ist es so schwierig?
Nein, weiß ich nicht. Fakt ist, da gebe ich dir recht, 25 bis 40 Prozent der Tore entstehen daraus. Punkt. Das ist eine Hausmarke. Genau. Das ist richtig. Die Bayern haben es letztes Jahr deutlich besser gemacht. Sie haben hinten raus auch – ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, welches Spiel es war, es war ein Auswärtsspiel in der Champions League, ich glaube es war das Viertelfinale – entschieden durch so eine Standardsituation. Da hat sich schon auch was getan. Beim DFB hat sich auch was getan. Genau, das kann gut sein. Eine Zeit lang wurde darauf vielleicht weniger Wert gelegt, und man hat bei der Europameisterschaft definitiv Muster gesehen, mit denen man versucht hat, hier gefährlicher zu werden. Ich glaube schon, dass es eine Rolle spielt, und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch nicht immer so einfach. Weil ich jetzt beispielsweise als Mannschaft, die unterlegen ist, würde meinen Spielern mit auf den Weg geben, Freunde, wenn die uns jetzt auszwirbeln und ausspielen, dann sind sie vielleicht besser bei einer Standardsituation. Also da lassen wir nichts zu.
Aber andererseits, da finde ich übrigens die Unterscheidung zwischen Männerfußball und Frauenfußball total interessant, denn bei Frauen sieht man noch viel, viel mehr Varianten der angreifenden Mannschaft bei Eckbällen. Also früher hat man oft gesehen, dass ich sich auf die Torhüterin draufgestellt habe, weil die in der Regel nicht so groß waren. Und tatsächlich hat das bei – also ich spreche jetzt viel von Turnieren, Vereinsfußball kriege ich nicht so viel mit bei den Frauen – und tatsächlich hat das gut funktioniert. Jetzt bei der aktuellen – bei Olympia hat man zum Beispiel gesehen, dass es, ich glaube, zwei, vielleicht sogar drei Mannschaften gab. Und die Deutschen haben das auch bei einigen der Ecken gemacht, dass alle Spieler sich am langen Fünfer Eck positioniert haben und dann erst in dem Moment, wo der Ball in der Luft war, dann fächerförmig aufgeteilt haben. Warum sehe ich denn solche Muster nicht seltener? Oder auch dieses klassische, dass Spieler, Knoil, alle Spieler der eigenen Mannschaft stehen so eng beieinander, dass sie nicht in Manndeckung genommen werden können und explodieren dann quasi in dem Moment, wo der Ball in der Luft ist. Warum sieht man sowas so selten?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich kann es dir nicht beantworten. Ich glaube, wenn ich es jetzt mal einordnen möchte, hat das ja mit Ballbesitzfußball zu tun. Weil ich habe den Ball. Und wie will ich da jetzt Kapital drausschlagen? Ich glaube, dass das insgesamt noch ein bisschen kreativer werden kann. Und für mich ist Taktik sehr nah an Kreativität. Weil ich mir Lösungen überlege, mit denen ich im Vorteil bin. Und jetzt bei einer Ecke zum Beispiel die Beispiele, die du genannt hast. Oder ich bloque jemanden frei oder ähnliches, was man schon immer wieder sieht.
Müller gegen Brasilien, das 1 zu 0. Klose wunderbar freigeblockt.
Zum Beispiel, das hat man auch bei der Europameisterschaft häufig gesehen. Ich denke auch, dass da Potenzial da ist. Ich denke, dass insgesamt im Erspielen von Toren und Torschossen einfach Potenzial da ist. Wo ich mir einfach kreative Möglichkeiten überlegen muss. Wie will ich jetzt vielleicht für einen Überraschungseffekt sorgen? Warum lässt sich nicht einer meiner Spieler aus dem zentralen Mittelfeld mal ganz in die Spitze fallen oder auf die Seite fallen oder was weiß ich? Und das resultiert in verschiedenen Positionswechseln und so. Und das sind so Punkte, die mir teilweise einfach noch so ein bisschen fehlen. Vielleicht geht es auch mir nur so, weil ich das gerne sehe, weil ich auch gerne Muster erkenne, weil dann kann ich welche erkennen.
Ja, Herr Schmink, wir sind beide Freunde von Hussein, das kann man schon sagen.
Vielleicht kommt es aus der Schiene, aber gleichzeitig ist es halt so, dass ich gegen die mittlerweile sehr gut verteidigenden Mannschaften, egal ob bei der Ecke oder im freien Spiel, einfach die Möglichkeit habe, für Räume für mich zu sorgen und da gewisse Zielspieler in gewisse Zielräume zu bringen. Nichts anderes hat Guardiola gemacht. Das war im Grunde immer ein ähnlicher Ansatz. Es ging um die zwei äußeren Spieler, Ribéry, Robben, wie sie alle hießen. Und alles, was vorher passierte, waren immer wieder mal Positionswechsel. Ziel war aber eigentlich immer, diese Spieler dort in vorteilhafte Situationen zu bringen. Und dazu muss ich aber auch den Mut haben, dass ich den Ball haben will. Wenn ich den Ball habe, dann steigert das mein Fehlerpotenzial.
Und ich muss die Spieler haben, die das können. Also mit dem Bayern jetzt den Ball haben zu wollen, ist weniger mutig als mit dem HSV zum Beispiel. Die haben auch recht viel tatsächlich den Ball haben.
Das stimmt. Da gebe ich dir erstmal recht. Und Bayern ist da immer ein Extrembeispiel. Aber ich meine, alle anderen sind Bundesligaspieler. Also die haben ein Niveau. Und zwar ein ganz schönes Niveau, dass die da oben in der Bundesliga kicken. Und ich glaube, dass da teilweise noch mehr rauszuholen ist. Und vielleicht macht sogar den Spieler manchmal noch ein bisschen mehr Spaß, wenn sie den Ball am Fuß haben und ihm nicht die ganze Zeit hinterherlaufen müssen.
Ja, hinter dieser These würde ich auch stehen. Auch aus meiner persönlichen sehr, sehr leidenhaften Fußballerfahrung ist es einfach besser, wenn man den Ball hat, alles andere nervt. Und dann fällt einem jeder Meter, dem man läuft, noch viel, viel mehr auf. Wenn man den Ball hinterher sprinten kann, dann läuft man nochmal den extra Kilometer, dem man nie gejoggt wäre. Genau so ist es. Das heißt, um diese Frage kreisen wir jetzt eigentlich schon seit einiger Zeit, dass wir beide feststellen, der Fußball hat sich dahingehend entwickelt, dass das Verteidigen sehr, sehr gut ausgearbeitet ist, das Arbeiten gegen den Ball. Was erwartest du denn jetzt für Entwicklungen dann im Spiel mit dem Ball?
Also ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass das Thema Kreativität eine große Rolle spielt. Also man hat auch gesehen, wie sich Dortmund entwickelt hat. Da hatten wir vorher mal angesprochen, da sind einfach immer wieder neue Lösungsmöglichkeiten dazu gekommen. Bestes Beispiel ist so die Renaissance auch der Dreierkette, die jetzt irgendwie auch wieder aufkam. Weil man, wenn man eine Dreierkette spielt und damit das Spiel eröffnet, dann habe ich halt gewisse Vorteile, wie wenn ich jetzt mit der Viererkette spiele. Und solche Entwicklungen, glaube ich, werden immer wieder kommen. Und ich glaube, dass sich Systeme immer wieder mal verändern. Ich glaube, dass wir mittlerweile sehr viel über den Fußball wissen. Also ich glaube, dass da wirklich sehr viel geforscht wurde. Ich glaube, dass mittlerweile sehr genau auf alles geschaut wird. Und ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass immer wieder neue Ideen hinzukommen, wie man gewisse Positionen einsetzen kann. Bestes Beispiel, auch wieder Guardiola oder auch Löw. Plötzlich tauchen die Außenverteidiger im Zentrum auf. So, dadurch, dass der Außenverteidiger ins Zentrum geht, habe ich plötzlich eine Überzahl im Zentrum. Naja, dann spiele ich halt übers Zentrum. Oder der Gegenspieler vom Außenverteidiger sagt, hä, scheiße, mein Gegenspieler läuft ins Zentrum hinterher. Naja, und plötzlich geht der Raum auf der Außenbahn auf. Und das sind die Dinge, um die mir es persönlich geht, die ich auch cool finde dann, weil man sich da einfach was einfallen lässt, um dem Gegner dann einen Schritt voraus zu sein.
Und trotzdem würde ich sagen, obwohl die Spieler heutzutage viel, viel besser ausgebildet sind als noch vor 15 Jahren, also da muss man glaube ich nicht lange drüber diskutieren, das erkennt man, wenn man sich Bundesligaspiele anguckt, finde ich, dass diese aktuelle Entwicklung ein paar Mannschaften, die eine sehr hohe individuelle Klasse haben, bevorteit gegenüber anderen Mannschaften. Also ich glaube einfach, dass es viel, viel schwieriger ist, diese kreativen Lösungen, die am Reißbrett wunderbar sind, aber die ja immer noch auf den Rasen gebracht werden müssen. Ich glaube, dass das für Mannschaften wie Dortmund, wie Bayern, jetzt auch Schalke und da weiß ich, da bin ich total gespannt, was sich verändert, Gladbach sowieso, für die ist das viel, viel einfacher umzusetzen. Und deswegen habe ich so ein bisschen die Sorge ehrlich gesagt, dass die Schere zwischen den Mannschaften das Leistungsgefälle noch ein bisschen auseinandergeht.
Das sehe ich nicht so ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde, das – und das hat mir meine persönliche Erfahrung gezeigt – dass wenn du ein entsprechendes Funktionsteam hast, das heißt wirklich auch mit einem Chef-Trainer, der offen dafür ist, mit einem Co-Trainer-Team, wo dann zum Beispiel auch der Co-Trainer-Analyse dazugehört, wenn ihr da gut arbeitet, wenn du eine klare Spielkonzeption hast, dann kannst du auch bei einer Mannschaft, die vielleicht sehr jung ist und die erstmal auf dem Papier der anderen unterlegen ist, denen Vorteile erarbeiten, weil dir vielleicht eigentlich sonst auch nichts übrig bleibt.
Das heißt, man braucht Special-Coaches, so wie in der NFL so ein bisschen?
Ja, Special-Coaches, wie man sie nennt, sei dahingestellt. Aber ja, Spezial-Trainer, klar, in jedem Fall. Ich glaube auch, dass das die Entwicklung weiterbringen wird, dass man Spezial-Trainer hat. Und wir haben ja schon Spezial-Trainer. Wir haben den Athletiktrainer. Wir haben dann die Physiotherapeuten. Wir haben den Torwarttrainer. Und wir haben mittlerweile auch einfach den Co-Trainer Analyse zum Beispiel. Und seine Aufgabe kann ja genau so was sein, in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Trainerteam diese Dinge zu entwickeln. Und natürlich wird es dann der Verein X vielleicht nicht gegen Dortmund oder Bayern spielen, weil dann vielleicht die Schere doch zu weit auseinandergeht. Aber gegen Mannschaften, die halt einem ungefähr auf einem Leistungsniveau begegnen, kann ich einen riesen Vorteil haben. Und das ist der Grund, warum ich da immer sage, okay, ist das vielleicht keine Ausrede?
Ich will dir ja sehr gerne glauben. Meine Ansicht ist die deprimierendere Ansicht. Andererseits habe ich auch manchmal den Eindruck, dass alles braucht Zeit. Und Zeit ist, glaube ich, das kostbarste Gut gerade im Profifußball. Und diese Zeit bekommt man heutzutage aber auch oft nicht mehr gerade, weil es so erfolgsgetrieben ist. Also ich finde ein hervorragendes, weil Positivbeispiel ist da der erste FC Köln-Unterstöger, der aus der zweiten Liga hochgekommen ist, dann das Spielsystem krass auf Defensive ausgelegt hat und der sich jetzt schrittweise in jeder der Bundesligaspielzeiten mehr dem Ballbesitzspiel, dem Offensivspiel zugewandt hat und es wurde von Saison zu Saison besser. Aber hätte das in der ersten Saison nicht hingehauen oder wäre es in der zweiten Saison schiefgegangen, dann hätte es gut sein können, dass Stöger weg ist und dann ist diese fortgeschritten Entwicklung weg. Und dann kommt vielleicht jemand mit einer anderen Idee.
Absolut. Ich finde es ein super cooles Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt. Es trifft genau auf den Punkt. Aber das ist dann leider auch der Profifußball, in dem der Erfolg einfach mit dabei sein muss. Sonst musst du halt wieder gehen. Außer du bist vielleicht auch in einem Verein, der diese Entwicklung ein Stück weit mittragen will. Wobei die harte Frage ist, nur weil ich jetzt einen guten Fußballspiel und vielleicht genau die Dinge umsetze, bin ich vielleicht nicht gleichzeitig sportlich erfolgreicher. Das ist ja immer dieses Rad, in dem wir uns befinden. Deswegen ist es auch ein gesunder Mittelweg, sich auch nicht zu stark in eine Prozessorientierung zu verfallen. Das heißt, sich nicht nur auf den Prozess zu konzentrieren, was ich jetzt alles machen kann und wie kreativ ich sein kann. Und sobald ich dann von mir aus an der gegnerischen Grundlinie angekommen bin, dann feiere ich mich, weil ich sage, diese Art und Weise wie ich es jetzt schon seit Wochen im Training trainiere, ich bringe halt wieder die Flanke und sie geht hinter das Tor. Das ist für mich dann die falsche Prozessorientierung, wo man halt dann auch wieder sehr starke Zielorientierung braucht und sagt, ok, das Ziel ist ein Tor zu machen. Und wenn ich aus 30 Metern schieße und der dreimal abgefälscht ist, zufälligerweise, naja, dann ist er drin und ich gewinne das Spiel 1 zu 0.
So, das Bayern mal gegen Chelsea ausgeschieden. Im Hin und im Rückspiel hat Lucio einen Fernschuss abgefälscht. Felix Maggert war das noch. Ich glaube, das war auch in der Saison, wo er dann gehen musste, weil er nur das Dugel geholt hat. Schlimme Zeiten für die Bayern waren das damals. Ich finde, wir haben jetzt schon mehrfach einen auch noch wichtigen Aspekt angesprochen, über den du auch allein schon aufgrund deiner Vita sehr gut Bescheid weißt. Wir saßen jetzt quasi virtuell die ganze Zeit vom Laptop und haben uns Spiele angeguckt und vom Reißbrett. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriege ich das ins Training rein? Also wir haben jetzt, sagen wir einfach mal, drei kleine Portionen, wo wir uns gesagt haben, ok, der Matchplan für das nächste Spiel wird diese drei Elemente beinhalten. Wer übernimmt eigentlich dann im Trainerstab die Aufgabe, das in Übung umzusetzen? Ist das eine Chef-Trainer-Sache? Welche Rolle spielen da die Co-Trainer?
Total unterschiedlich. Also das wird verschiedenste gehandhabt, angefangen von der Lösung, dass jetzt der Analyst, sage ich mal, gar nicht in die Trainingsgestaltung involviert ist, sondern eben nur seine Erkenntnisse weitergibt, vielleicht auch nochmal diskutiert. Und das Trainerteam, das dann umsetzt, bis hin zum anderen Extrem, dass der Co-Trainer-Analyse sozusagen dann auch die Erkenntnisse mit dem Cheftrainer und dem Trainerteam bespricht und sie dann auch vielleicht sogar selbst auf dem Platz mit umsetzt in Form von Trainingsübungen. Das hängt natürlich immer von der Arbeitsweise ab.
Wie hat sich denn da die Trainingswissenschaft entwickelt und ist das ein Teil auch jetzt zum Beispiel eurer Zertifikatausbildung? Ich würde fast sagen, das ist so ein bisschen die Kühe. Die Spielanalyse, das ist wichtig und das ist fordernd, das ist auch nicht leicht. Aber die Kühe ist ja dann eigentlich mit den einzelnen Bits, die ich mir da rausgezogen habe, das dann quasi wieder auf den Rasen zu bringen.
Richtig, der letzte elementare Schritt, für den man eigentlich alles vorher macht. Im Zertifikat haben wir es drinnen, ja. Wobei, wie gesagt, das sind einfach Dinge, die dann einfach auch in Kompetenzen übergehen, die zum Beispiel halt einfach einen Trainer haben muss, wo man sehr nah zum Beispiel dann auch an der Fußballlehrerausbildung ist, wo es darum geht, die Inhalte, die man nun hat, in trainingspraktische Maßnahmen umzusetzen und zu sehen, wie weit bin ich denn schon mit meinem Leistungsstand? Also muss ich anfangen und einen 8 oder 9 gegen 0 spielen, um einfach die Laufwege zum Beispiel einzuschleifen und zu üben? Oder kann ich schon den Gegner mit dazu nehmen, fiktiv, der dann zum Beispiel am Wochenende halt meinen Gegner simuliert und dem sein System spielt? Wie weit bin ich da? Und dann kann man da natürlich sehr methodische Schritte auch gehen, um das Ganze ins Training umzusetzen. Wer das macht, wie gesagt, das ist etwas, was verschiedenste gehandhabt wird.
Thomas Tuchel sagt ja immer – oder hat zumindest gesagt – It's not a coach's game, it's a player's game. Das spricht ja jetzt gegen viel über das wir gesprochen haben oder nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, dass ein wesentliches Ziel der Spielanalyse ist, seine eigenen Spieler stärker zu machen.
Jürgen Klinsmann, Vorreiter.
Auf eine gewisse Weise ganz bestimmt, klar. Ich bin immer gerne bei dem Beispiel Gegneranalyse, weil das sehr greifbar ist. Ich will ja im Grunde nichts anderes als meine Mannschaft auf den kommenden Gegner einzustellen. Da bin ich ja direkt beim Spieler. Ich will mich ja nicht selber abfeiern, weil ich eine coole Analyse gemacht habe, die eigentlich den Spielern nicht interessiert. Das ist so der eine Punkt. Der zweite Punkt ist der, dass man natürlich auch vieles machen kann, um die Stärken der einzelnen Spieler hervorzuheben. Wir hatten vorher das Beispiel Guardiola mit Robben und Ribéry. Wenn ich meine Mannschaft gut kenne, wenn ich weiß, was die Stärken sind, dann versuche ich diese natürlich auch immer wieder zu provozieren. Das kann ich dann, wenn ich weiß, wie der Gegner agiert, weil ich wissen muss, wie verteidigt er zum Beispiel. Und dann kann ich das Ganze umsetzen. Und klar, es kommt ein wesentlicher Punkt noch dazu. Das ist der Bereich Individualität, den vor allem im Profifußball weit verbreitet ist. Wo Persönlichkeiten rumlaufen, die dann auch nicht immer einfach zu haben sind bei den Spielern, das ist völlig klar. Und die gilt es aber da auch irgendwie einzufangen und im besten Fall stark zu machen. Und vielleicht auch mal aus dem System, aus dem Taktischen völlig rauszulassen. Wer weiß, da gibt es ja verschiedene Lösungsansätze. Und deswegen stimme ich mit dem Zitat von Herrn Tuchel erstmal auch völlig überein.
Wie würdest du sagen, hat sich so die Spielegeneration verändert? Ich meine, du hast ja einen relativ nahen Blick auf die Entwicklung in den letzten Jahren. Man sagt ja immer, dass es kein Zufall ist, dass jetzt auch die heutigen Nationalspieler eher die Generation ist, die auch Abitur gemacht hat, begleitend zur Fußballausbildung und so weiter. Und ich möchte es jetzt nicht nur auf so platte Bildungsdinge reduzieren, aber es ist ja schon eine eloquente Spielergeneration, eine taktisch gut geschulte Spielergeneration durch die Entwicklung in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren innerhalb der letzten Jahre. Was glaubst du, hat sich da so in den letzten Jahren verändert?
Ja, ich glaube schon genau das, was du angesprochen hast. Und das macht es im Übrigen auch heutzutage sehr schwierig für den Trainer, für den Cheftrainer im Profifußball.
Macht es nicht leichter, weil er hinterfragt wird oder warum?
Also es macht es ihm vielleicht erstmal leichter, weil er Spieler kriegt, die ihm wahrscheinlich extrem gut ausgebildet sind. Oder streichen wir das wahrscheinlich, sie sind extrem gut ausgebildet. Fakt ist aber auch, dass natürlich diese Ausbildung, die die Spieler hatten, hat er zwangsläufig zur Folge, dass sie unfassbar gute Trainer hatten, die auch schon taktisch sehr, sehr gut geschult waren. Und da gibt es, denke ich, in den deutschen Nachwuchsleistungszentren einige. Und als Cheftrainer musst du natürlich auch nochmal einen draufsetzen, inhaltlicher Natur und taktischer Natur, was, glaube ich, heutzutage gar nicht mehr so einfach ist. Interessante Aspekt. Klar hat die Trainerrolle auch viel mit anderen Aspekten zu tun. Nicht nur mit Taktischen, sondern es geht viel um Führung. Du musst deinen ganzen Stab führen, du musst die Mannschaft führen und so. Das ist schon auch eine ganz besondere Rolle und Aufgabe. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht immer einfach für den Trainer. Ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht, ob ich damit eine Frage beantwortet habe.
Na ja, im Grunde schon, dadurch, dass wir uns einig sind, dass sich die Spieler in en gros quasi verändert haben in ihrer Auffassungsgabe und in ihrer Schulung. Die Anschlussfrage, die sich da für mich so ein bisschen stellt, ist, in diesem Bereich der Spielerausbildung hat ja auch der DFB eine maßgebliche Rolle gespielt. Also 2000 wird immer so als Stunde Null im deutschen Fußball bezeichnet. Dann gab es die Einführung der Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Es wurde verpflichtend, dass auch die Bundesligisten Nachwuchsleistungszentren hatten. Es gab einen gewissen Goldstandard, den man erreichen konnte. So wurde das peu à peu in der Bundesliga etabliert. Nicht nur die Engländer schauen jetzt sehr neidisch hier rüber, was für eine Spielergeneration wir jetzt haben, sondern auch die Franzosen, die ja selbst ein sehr gutes Nachwuchsleistungskonzept haben. Auch die gucken immer wieder nach Deutschland und schauen, wie hat das der DFB eigentlich zusammen mit der DFL hinbekommen. Und gleichzeitig setzt man aber natürlich dann dadurch, dass die Trainer ja alle dieselbe Schule durchlaufen haben, nämlich den DFB-Fußballlehrer, die Ausbildung, setzt man ja auch so ein paar Grundfundamente, wie man Fußball spielt, wie man über Fußball denkt. Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass jetzt fast die interessantesten Spieler aktuell welche sind, die nicht in das Raster der normalen Spieler reinpassen. Also wenn wir es vielleicht mal an einem Beispiel machen wollen, nicht nur bei der Europameisterschaft hieß es, ja uns fehlt halt vielleicht mal jemand, der auch mal im 1 gegen 1 ein Tripling gewinnt oder der mal etwas Verrücktes probiert, das was Franck Ribéry seit Jahren beim FC Bayern macht. Das ist für mich so ein kleines Indiz für das, was ich vorher ausgeführt habe. Siehst du es ähnlich?
Also ich glaube erstmal, dass man, finde ich, nicht sagen kann, dass wenn dieselbe Schule durchlaufen wird, dass dasselbe Wissen und dasselbe Denken bedeutet. Ich glaube, dass es einfach Fundamente im Fußball gibt. Die verändern sich nicht. Die verändern sich auch in anderen Ländern nicht. Und so wie ich die Fußballlehrerausbildung kennengelernt habe, auch wenn ich sie nicht selber gemacht habe, aber da schon immer viel mitgekriegt habe, dann geht es da schon auch sehr viel um Selbstreflektion und sich selbst weiterzuentwickeln, inhaltlich, so wie eben auch als Trainer. Wo eben nicht irgendwas nach dem Motto hingeschoben wird, so ist es und fertig. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein wichtiger Ansatz. Deswegen finde ich eigentlich die Art und Weise, wie man davor geht, sehr gut. Nichtsdestotrotz hat man es jetzt auch ein bisschen gemerkt, dass schon ähnliche Spielertypen zuletzt immer aus dem Nachwuchsleistungszentrum so ein bisschen rausploppten, die dann auch zum Star wurden und in der Nationalmannschaft drankamen. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das vielleicht eine relativ normale Entwicklung ist. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass man eigentlich immer auch nach den großen Turnieren lächzte man nach gewissen Positionen. Ich kann mich erinnern, es war eine Zeit lang eben genau der kreative Mittelfeldspieler, der uns dann gefehlt hat, der jetzt aber vielfach eben ausgebildet wurde, weil man da vielleicht einen besonderen Fokus drauf gelegt hat. Und jetzt fehlen uns halt vielleicht wieder andere Spieler. Und da fehlt auch der Mittelstürmer zum Beispiel, der eine große Rolle in dem Zusammenhang spielt. Deswegen ist es vielleicht so ein normaler Prozess. Gleichzeitig kann es aber auch, denke ich, für die Nachwuchsleistungszentren sensibilisieren, eben zu versuchen, keine Raster auszubilden, sondern da wirklich auch eine Freiheit zu lassen und die verschiedenen Positionsprofile, die halt existieren, auch auszubilden.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine provokante Frage. Aber meinst du, dass diese Gleichförmigkeit der Spiele, die jetzt in die Nationalmannschaft geschafft haben, dass es auch ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, wie über Fußball heutzutage berichtet wird und wie wahrscheinlich auch wir zwei über Fußball urteilen? Also ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, in den letzten Jahren ging es sehr, sehr krass um Fehlerminimierung, weil es tatsächlich irgendwann so war, wenn vorne der Rechtsaußen im 1 gegen 1 den Ball verloren hat und daraufhin gab es die Umscheißsituation des Gegentor, dann war das vielleicht vor zehn Jahren noch so, dass nicht alle mit dem Finger auf den Rechtsaußen gezeigt haben, weil man damals noch ein bisschen einen anderen Blick hatte. Heutzutage kann man sich aber schon ziemlich sicher sein, dass auch in der Massenbilderberichterstattung, dass schon thematisiert wird, da vorne war der Ballverlust. Deswegen habe ich so den Eindruck, es ging immer mehr darum, keine Fehler zu machen, damit man nicht im Fokus der Öffentlichkeit steht.
Ja, das ist eine These. Ich finde zunächst, diese Gleichförmigkeit, die du angesprochen hast, wenn man sie positiv auslegt, dann sind es Spezialisten, die man ausgebildet hat. Spezialisten auf ihren Positionen, zum Beispiel Außenverteidiger. Ein Kimmich, der ausgebildet wurde jetzt, der vielleicht auch an Philipp Lahm erinnert, ist erstmal jemand, der unfassbar viele Attribute mitbringt, wo man sagt, hey, das ist das, was wir suchen als Außenverteidiger, der jetzt auch in Norwegen das Tor gemacht hat, sodass diese Gleichförmigkeit, also diese Ausbildung von Spezialisten, für mich erstmal nichts Schlechtes ist. Das hat ja auch einen positiven Aspekt. Und den anderen Aspekt, den du genannt hast, ist da sehr viel von den Medien getragen. Ich finde es schwer zu beurteilen, ehrlich gesagt. Fehlervermeidung, ja. Auf der anderen Seite – und da kann ich es eigentlich wieder runterbrechen – auch Fehlervermeidung ist Spiel gegen den Ball. Vielleicht ist es der Grund, warum das viele Mannschaften sehr intensiv machen, weil sie eben dann keine Fehler machen können, weil sie den Ball nicht haben. Wenn du den Ball hast, dann bist du mutig und kannst halt Fehler machen. Aber es ist ja auch so, dass Spieler, die 15 Mal was versuchen, mehr Fehler machen werden, als Spieler, die nur fünf Mal was versuchen. Das finde ich einen schwierigen Punkt. Ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass die Medien – und eigentlich schließe ich mich da ein bisschen ein, weil ich bin ja im Grunde auch tätig für Medien – dass man da vielleicht dem Ganzen ein bisschen positiver gegenübersteht. Und auch ein Mario Götze, der unfassbar in der Kritik gerade ist, auch von Jens Lehmann, der ja ganz schön eine Schelte gekriegt hat, dass man das ein bisschen analytischer angeht. Und wenn wir von Ursachen sprechen, auch die tatsächlichen Ursachen versuchen zu finden. Du hast zum Beispiel Ballverlust angesprochen und dann wirklich auch auf die Fehlerkette eingehen, die dahinter steckt und nicht nur dieses eine finden wollen.
Ja gut, letztlich landen wir dann bei einem generellen Problem. Es ist immer einfacher zu verkürzen und das ist auch die spitzere Schlagzeile. Mario Götz ist ja das perfekte Beispiel. Bevor er sich bei den Bayern verletzt hat, das war die Phase, wo eigentlich alle, auch die Mainstream-Medien geschrieben hatten, er scheint angekommen zu sein. Da hat er in der Champions League mehrere entscheidende Tore gespielt. Da hatte er seinen festen Platz in der Mannschaft. Da waren zwar auch noch ein paar andere Spieler verletzt, aber er hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt einen absoluten Stammplatz. Dann hat er sich verletzt und als er zurückkam, waren andere Spieler wieder fit. Er hat dann nicht mehr in der entscheidenden Saisonphase den Weg in die Mannschaft gefunden. Dann ist es aber natürlich die größere Schlagzeile zu sagen, Götze bei Bayern endgültig gescheitert, als zu sagen, er hat jetzt auch einfach ein bisschen Pech gehabt. Das ist für Guardiola auch schwierig, in einem Champions League-Viertelfinale, was spitz auf Knopf steht, und in einem Halbfinale Götze reinzuschmeißen. Es ist schon ein Fakt, dass er es nicht getan hat. Darüber kann ich berichten. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Das, was wir uns wünschen würden, sind Grautöne, aber die sind halt auch langweiliger. Das ist halt kein Schwarz oder kein Weiß.
Ja klar, und Fußball ist einfach da auch unglaublich schnelllebig. Wenn er jetzt drei Hütten macht in den nächsten drei Spielen, dann ist er mal kurz einfach wieder der King. Dann interessiert einen das, was vorher war, nicht mehr. Deswegen, glaube ich, ist eher die Frage, wie geht der Spieler Mario Götze einfach damit um, mit diesen Medien? Klar ist, dass das an keiner menschlichen Person einfach mal so vorbeigeht. Also es tangiert ihn in irgendeiner Form mit Sicherheit. Ich hoffe nur, dass es nicht zu sehr ist, dass er einfach aus diesem Leistungstief so wieder rauskommt.
Okay, wir wollen es jetzt auch gar nicht auf Mario Götze hier reduzieren. Mich befällt da ein fast körperliches Unbehagen, weil ich nicht nahe genug an den Spielern dran bringe. Da mache ich dann immer ganz schnell auch in der Schlusskonferenz dicht. Da muss man jetzt einfach gucken, was er auf den Platz bringt. Dafür muss man ihn aber auch noch zehn Spiele mehr spielen lassen, als die paar, die jetzt gespielt sind in dieser Saison.
Taktisch muss ich dann schon noch mal für ihn in die Presse springen. Ich will ihn nicht verteidigen oder ähnliches. Das ist ganz neutral, aber die Art und Weise der Länderspiele, wie sie zuletzt liefen, ist halt auch einfach überhaupt nicht sein Spiel, wenn er auf der Position gespielt hat. Und selbst wenn er vielleicht weiter außen gespielt hat, wo er unfassbar wenig Platz hatte, auch immer gegen diese tiefstehenden Gegner, das ist jetzt keine Neuigkeit. Davon redet man auch regelmäßig. Aber man muss diesen Faktor halt auch mit einbeziehen. Und es geht anderen Spielern ja genauso. Es geht einem Draxler genauso. Und ein Thomas Müller hat auch richtig Stress gehabt, weil er so wenig Raum hatte usw. usf. Und dann ist die Frage ja, dann ist halt mal wieder ein Zufall da. Und dann steht er halt mal wieder richtig. Das sind dann auch so Sachen, die sind dann völlig ungreifbar. Aber wenn wir es jetzt taktisch begründen, dann muss man jetzt auch erst mal wieder abwarten, bis er in einem System eingesetzt wird, das ihm halt auch liegt.
Das stimmt. Und richtiger Punkt auch mit dem Zufall. Ich meine, Deutschland gegen Norwegen, Norwegen liegt nur zu eins hinten, steht immer noch 20 Meter vor dem Tor mit neun Mann. Alles ist wahnsinnig eng, da ist es total schwierig für Götze. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, ein Beispiel in die andere Richtung. Deutschland gegen Italien 4 zu 1 hier in München. Alle sagen, Götze hat wieder ein Tor gemacht, er ist einfach bei der Nationalmannschaft, führte sich zu Hause. Und das Tor war das untypischste Götze-Tor aller Zeiten. Das war eine No-Look-Flanke von Thomas Müller. Und er macht zwischen Bonucci und Cellini, glaube ich, ein Kopfballtor. Also überhaupt nichts, wo man sagen kann, er fühlt sich so zu Hause, sondern ja, halt zweimal Zufall. Damit sind wir ja schon eigentlich recht weit in dem Bereich der Frage, was für eine Medienberichterstattung man sich so wünschen könnte. Wir haben es immer schon wieder ein bisschen gestriffen, aber ein Bereich, der mich noch interessiert, ist die Terminologie. Gerade weil es jetzt so ist, dass es eben auch viele Autodidakten gibt, wie ja zum Beispiel auch mich, habe ich den Eindruck, dass manchmal ein bisschen aneinander vorbei geredet wird. Wie wichtig ist denn eine einheitliche Terminologie? Wie kann man die sich drauf schaffen?
Er ist tatsächlich unfassbar wichtig. Also in der Vereinsarbeit sowieso. Also da gibt es auch genügend Beispiele, in denen ein Vokabular wirklich festgelegt wird, dass ganz klar ist, was man unter was versteht, dass man eine Sprache spricht, dass man vielleicht sogar auch mit Zeichensprache mal an der Seitenlinie, weil es im Stadion halt so saulaut ist, mal kurz eine Info geben kann, ohne dass man drei Sätze irgendwie versucht, über 20 Meter zu schreiben.
Die berühmten Finger von Lucien Favre, zwei Zeigefinger, war glaube ich, dass er auf Viererkette umgestellt hat, wenn ich mich nicht verinner.
Und deswegen im Verein unabdingbar und entwickelt sich auch und kann man auch als teambildende Maßnahme mal einsetzen. Ich finde, in den Medien kann man das durchaus auch. Wobei es da schon schwierig ist, weil es einfach allein aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Arten des Sprechens in Deutschland schon unterschiedliche Wörter benutzt werden. Torhüter, Torspieler, Torwart. Das ist so ein Beispiel, das wird einfach unterschiedlich eingesetzt. Und da gibt es dann noch viel tiefere taktische Begriffe.
Aber da weiß ich ja, was gemeint ist.
Ja, das stimmt, dann war das jetzt vielleicht ein super banales Beispiel. Aber es gibt andere Begriffe, die einfach unterschiedlich verwendet werden können. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, ist es jetzt nicht zwingend notwendig, das zu vereinheitlichen für den gesamten Medienbetrieb sozusagen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass wenn man… wenn man… Wenn man jetzt von einem Sender oder ähnliches spricht, der seine Berichterstattung macht, glaube ich, ist es schon von Vorteil, dass man so grundlegende, untergrundlegende Dinge wirklich auch dasselbe versteht.
Was ich mir ja wünschen würde bei der Fußballberichterstattung ist, ich hätte gern einmal die Formation der Mannschaft mit dem Ball und einmal gegen den Ball. Ich frage mich, warum das nicht kommt. Jetzt, wenn die Mannschaftsausstellung gezeigt wird, manchmal finde ich es sogar geradezu witzig, wenn bei Gegnern der Bayern gezeigt wird, dass sie ganz toll in einem 4-2-3-1 stehen. Aber schon nach fünf Minuten sieht man ja, die Außen lassen sich aber so weit zurückfallen, dass es eine Fünfer- und manchmal eine Sechser-Kette ist. Warum wird sowas nicht einfach gemacht? Ist das dann vielleicht auch schon eine Detail-Ebene, die tatsächlich nur uns beide hier interessiert und vielleicht die, die jetzt gerade einen Rasenfunk hören?
Also ja, eine Frage, die ich mir auch schon seit langem stelle, weil es einfach prinzipiell so ist, dass wir zwei Positionierungen haben, mit dem Ball und gegen den Ball. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch so, dass ich von dieser statischen Grundordnung auch gar nicht so viel halte. Weil die haben wir im Spiel dann vielleicht mal zwei oder drei Mal, jeweils beim Anstoß, beim Gegentor so ungefähr. Und ansonsten bewegen wir uns sowieso wieder im System. Und das System verändert sich ständig. Und deswegen hat man ja dann auch immer wieder Heatmaps, wo dann Durchschnittspositionen oder Ähnliches angezeigt werden.
Die finde ich so wahnsinnig ungenau. Die sagen doch, außer bei Spielern, die einen klaren Fokus hatten, sagen diese Heatmaps nichts. Weil die Heatmaps würden dann quasi nur auf die Minutenbereiche hin viel aussagen können. Also wenn ich sagen könnte, zeig mir jetzt mal seine Bewegungs-Heatmap der ersten 15 Minuten, der nächsten 15 Minuten und so weiter. Solche Heatmaps mit so realtaktischen Positionen gibt es ja zum Beispiel von der FIFA bei der Weltmeisterschaft immer. Dann finde ich, hat das eine Aussagekraft. Aber so eine 90-Minuten-Heatmap, wo das Team einmal 0-1 hinten lag, dann das 1-1 gemacht hat und am Schluss mit 11 gegen 10 gespielt hat, bringt mir doch eine Heatmap nichts.
Ja, sehr schön. Aber jetzt hast du dich gerade deine Argumentation von ganz zu Beginn runtergekegelt, weil das sind nämlich Daten. Das sind Positionsdaten und das ist die Frage der Interpretation. Deswegen gebe ich dir recht und es gibt nicht nur die Möglichkeit, das zeitlich zu begrenzen, sondern man kann auch Spielsituationen herausfiltern. Also in denen es mich besonders interessiert, wie die Durchschnittsposition aussieht. Und mich interessiert es zum Beispiel jetzt nicht zwangsläufig, wenn ich jetzt allein unterscheide mit dem Ball und gegen den Ball, wie ist da die Durchschnittsposition? Weil da sind Momente dabei, in denen die in der völligen Unordnung sind. Sondern mich interessieren zum Beispiel Momente, in denen die mannschaftstaktisch anlaufen. Wo ich sage, okay so und jetzt agieren die aus ihrer Grundordnung 4-2-3-1, agieren die in ihrem System. Das ist der Unterschied. Grundordnung statisch, System dynamisch. Und wie bewegt sich dann dieses System sozusagen in dieser kurzen Anlaufphase, in denen zum Beispiel dann der spielt dann zwar den langen Ball oder die schaffen es irgendwie sich rauszukombinieren. Aber dann habe ich eine Information, wie die tatsächliche Positionierung eigentlich ist. Und dann bin ich auch wieder bei dem Punkt, naja, wie will ich die Daten einsetzen, sodass ich eine Information darüber kriege, was der Trainer wissen will. Und der Trainer will zum Beispiel genau solche Situationen wissen.
Ja gut, wobei wir jetzt im Bereich der Berichterstattung ein bisschen gelandet sind.
Ja, wobei das, glaube ich, in dieselbe Richtung geht.
Wobei mir jetzt zum Beispiel auch gerade schon aufgefallen ist, dass ich das Wort System anders verwende als du. Da sind wir auch schon wieder beim Terminologiebegriff. Ich spreche im System und meine damit die Grundordnung. Und du hast mir gerade gezeigt, was ja richtig ist, dass das das Dynamische ist. Jetzt muss ich ja auch gucken, dass ich das in der Schlusskonferenz immer hinkriege. Das wird was. Wir machen schon sehr lange, deswegen würde ich mal sagen, biegen wir mal so langsam auf die Zielgerade ein. Mich würde noch interessieren, mit welchen Quellen bildest du dich denn eigentlich weiter? Gibt es denn da eigentlich Literatur? Da ist das eigentlich ganz viel, dass du eben zum Beispiel mit einem Frank Wormuth Kontakt hast, dass du dich austauschen kannst. Es gibt ja auch nicht die eine richtige Wahrheit, sondern es ist ja eine ständige Diskussion. Das macht es ja auch sogar in dem Bereich so spannend. Also man kann immer über den Fußball reden, egal in welcher Detailtiefe und analytischen Tiefe man das machen will. Wie bildest du dich weiter?
Also mir ist erstmal total wichtig, da auch nochmal zu erwähnen, dass es eben tatsächlich nicht die eine Wahrheit gibt. Und all das, was ich jetzt so von meiner Seite berichtet habe, ist total subjektiv. Weil jemand anders sieht es auch wieder anders und bewertet eine Spielsituation auch vielleicht wieder anders. Und das ist auch unfassbar wichtig, sich das beizubehalten. Und ich hoffe, dass es so auch in einem Gespräch rüberkommt. Mir persönlich natürlich auch wichtig. Ich glaube, dass in der Spielanalyse und auch was Taktik betrifft, ist insgesamt der Austausch wirklich essentiell. Genau, mit meinen Kumpanen. Also was für mich ein enormer Mehrwert ist, ist tatsächlich der Austausch in den Projekten, die ich mache. Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise Champions League Spiele analysiere, dann auch mich mit den Personen auszutauschen, für die ich es analysiere, sozusagen. Also wirklich sehr, sehr projektbezogen. Aber jetzt ist es natürlich auch so, dass ich den absoluten Luxus habe, dass ich jetzt zum zweiten Mal als Programmleiter unser Hochschulzertifikat begleiten darf. Und da haben wir absolute Top-Dozenten, wenn ich mal einfach Vollwerbung machen darf, aber es ist so, die Top-Experten in ihrem Bereich sind. Das heißt, die dozieren durch diesen Tag und gleichzeitig sind aber auch Teilnehmer da, die sich unglaublich intensiv mit dem Bereich der Spielanalyse auseinandersetzen. Und diese Interaktion macht immer unfassbar viel Spaß, weil es ist immer wieder ein Verrückter dabei, der eine Idee äußert, wo man sich denkt, das gibt es doch nicht. Da habe ich noch nicht dran gedacht, was ist so naheliegend. Und in dem Fall ist es so, dass ich zum zweiten Mal diesen Lehrgang einfach mit durchlaufen kann, was natürlich jetzt für mich persönlich ein Riesen-Mehrwert ist, total interessant ist, und dadurch auch irgendwie immer wieder ein Wissensvorsprung dazu kommt.
Wer sind denn dazu? Beispielsweise die Experten, die da die einzelnen Module dozieren?
Also wir haben aktuell hatten wir angefangen bei den wissenschaftlichen Grundlagen, den Philipp Obloch da, von Opta, der natürlich sehr viel Daten basiert macht, den Dr. Hendrik Weber, der Spielanalyse strategisch leitet bei der Deutschen Fußballliga. Wir hatten dann zum Beispiel aber auch jemanden wie Lars Kornetka da oder Hammin da, der als Co-Trainer Analyse von Bayer Leverkusen unglaublich viel Wissen mitbringt, genauso wie der Benjamin Weber von Borussia Dortmund, der eine ähnliche Rolle hat. Wir haben den DFB mit im Boot über Christopher Clemens, der Spielanalyse und Scouting für die A-Nationalmannschaft leitet, genauso wie jetzt Björn Müller oder Ralf Peter, die einfach auch im Modul Fußballlehre dann als Dozent arbeiten. Das sind Johannes Spohr, den ich noch vergessen habe, der die Scouting-Abteilung bei Red Bull Leipzig leitet. Mir ist hoffentlich niemand böse, der das jetzt zuhörst und nicht genannt wird. Aber es sind einfach tolle Leute.
Und weißt du, was ich super finde? Von diesen zehn Namen kannte ich zwei. Ich finde das total faszinierend. Es gibt einfach Bereiche des Fußballs und ich beschäftige mich jetzt nun wirklich schon ein paar Jahre intensiver mit den Bereichen. Nicht zuletzt für den Rasenfunk. Aber es gibt einfach Bereiche, die sind einem halbwegs tief eingedrungenen Line verschlossen. Und das ist nochmal so eine ganz eigene Ebene. Das finde ich super, total spannend. Die muss ich jetzt alle googeln, wenn ich da bin.
Mach das gerne, du findest sie auf unserer Internetseite. Aber das ist, glaube ich, das charakterisiert dieses Berufsbild auch wieder, um da nochmal irgendwie anzuschließen. Ich finde, es gibt so einen Leitspruch, den habe ich mir so ein bisschen auch auf die Fahne geschrieben, den ich ganz cool finde, der geht – work hard in silence, let success be your noise. Das ist, finde ich, ein cooler Leitspruch, der dieses Berufsbild einfach so ein Stück weit trifft, weil sie viel im Hintergrund arbeiten, weil sie nicht diejenigen sind, die jetzt die Chef-Trainer-Rolle haben oder ähnliches, die aber schon auch, wenn sie im Verein gut eingesetzt werden, eine tragende Rolle spielen können.
Jetzt hast du so lange deine Kompetenz bewiesen, dass ich diese Frage jetzt auch stellen kann. Gab es schon mal ein Spiel, wo du dich richtig veranalysiert hast, wo du Dinge rausgelesen hast von einem Gegner und dann haben die komplett anders gespielt und du hast dir gedacht, heine, nein, was habe ich denn da geliefert?
Ja klar.
Und dann in den Senkel gestellt worden vom Trainer?
Nee, ach, wenn man es gut analysiert, dann hat es der Analyst toll gemacht. Wenn man es schlecht analysiert und die Mannschaft schlecht spielt, dann ist die Mannschaft schuld. So, nein, klar, aber ich meine, wenn ich es vorhersagen könnte, dann wäre mein Marktwert deutlich höher.
Ja, vor allem müsstest du dann nicht mehr arbeiten, weil du Sportwettenkönig wärst.
Das kommt noch mit dazu und das ist Berufsrisiko. Da vertippt man sich natürlich regelmäßig. Ich sag mal, wenn man jetzt für die Medien arbeitet, ist es nochmal was anderes. Da schaut man ein bisschen neutraler auch drauf und dann kann man ungefähr abschätzen, was vielleicht da jetzt auch kommt. Wenn man jetzt im Verein arbeitet und man muss dem Trainer halt einfach eine Info geben und sagen, so und ich erwarte das so, bab, bab, bab, bab und dann tritt es nicht ein. Naja, weil die sich vielleicht auf uns auch vorbereitet haben oder wie auch immer.
Und abschließende Frage, kannst du ein Fußballschuh eigentlich noch so richtig genießen oder rattert es bei dir sofort los, wenn der Innenverteidiger den Ball rausspielt auf den Außenverteidiger, denkst du dir, ach, sehr interessant, muss ich mir merken und so weiter.
Ein Fußballspiel oder in Fußballschuhen?
Ein Fußballspiel.
Ja, ich kann es schon genießen irgendwie, weil…
Irgendwie.
Ja, also es ist was anderes. Ich glaube, jeder, der sich einfach damit intensiv auseinandersetzt, der achtet einfach zwangsläufig auf Dinge und schaut dann nochmal genauer hin. Ich glaube, da stecken wir irgendwie alle so ein bisschen in einem Boot, auch die sich einfach für die ganze Materie interessieren. Da würde ich jetzt nicht den Fußballfan, der vielleicht tatsächlich einfach beruflich gar nichts mit dem Fußball zu tun hat, in ein Boot setzen mit demjenigen, der einfach viel mit dem Fußball zu tun hat, wenn da das Interesse da ist. Das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Also kannst du das nicht ausblenden. Bei mir geht es zum Beispiel so, ich gucke nur deswegen gerne Europa League, weil ich keine Europa League-Ausgaben im Rasenfunk mache, weil diese Spiele bis zu so einer gewissen K.o.-Rundenphase auch eine relativ geringe Bedeutung für die Bundesliga haben. Und da genieße ich das manchmal wahnsinnig. Bei der Champions League kann ich mich nicht zurücklehnen. Da muss ich gucken, wie Gladbach, Dortmund, Leverkusen, wie die Bayern spielen. Denn das sind einfach Erkenntnisse, die sammeln sich auch so automatisch. Aber bei der Europa League zum Beispiel kann ich das. Oder auch bei der 2. Bundesliga. Da nimmt das jetzt zwar immer mehr zu, weil so viele Hörer fragen, ob ich was zur 2. Liga mache. Da habe ich so langsam den Eindruck, ich muss da langsam mal drauf achten. Aber ich kann mich dann tatsächlich zurückzulehnen. Dann mache ich auch Twitter nebenher auf. Und dann denke ich mir, ach schön, jetzt lasse ich mich einfach mal überraschen, ob das ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Spiel wird. Also ich kann es noch manchmal ausschalten.
Ja, doch, so geht es mir schon auch. Zumal ja auch, man verändert ja auch den Blick, wenn man anfängt, die Dinge zu analysieren. Man muss ja auch auf Dinge achten und man kann nicht zwischendrin mal wegschauen und noch einen Schluck trinken oder was weiß ich. Man muss ja irgendwie so ein bisschen dranbleiben. Und deswegen kann ich das schon auf eine gewisse Weise. Und trotzdem hat sich aber einfach insgesamt mein Blick auf den Fußball verändert. Und das hat aber einfach damit zu tun, dass ich die Ehre hatte, mich jetzt einfach die letzten Jahre sehr intensiv damit beschäftigen zu dürfen. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht einfach manchmal ein anderer Blick drauf.
Ja, ja und vielleicht hilft es mir dann tatsächlich auch, dass ich nur die Fernsehbilder habe. Das macht es natürlich bei den Spielen, die ich dann tiefer analysieren will, macht es schwieriger, weil ich mir ganz viel Informationen ziehen muss. Also deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich auch noch abhängiger von Daten, auch allein von Positionsdaten von Außenverteidigern, weil ich die halt einfach ganz oft nicht sehe. Wenn die Beinen vorne den Ball haben, dann zeigen die nicht, wie hoch die gerade stehen. Vielleicht ist das noch tatsächlich das, was da ein bisschen hilft, ein bisschen distanzierter, sich das Ganze anzugucken. Alex, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht. Ich hätte dir gerne noch irgendeine Anekdote rausgeleiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mir noch irgendetwas erzählen kannst, was dir für immer in Erinnerung bleiben wird, wenn du auf deine Jahre als Spielanalyst zurückblickst. Du kannst dir Namen verfälschen.
Nein, ich habe ja vorher schon eine kleine Anekdote mit den gelaufenen Kilometern erzählt, die Richtung Fan-Kurve. Das war für mich so ein Meilenstein, wo ich gesagt habe, sei vorsichtig, wie du diese Daten interpretierst, weil sie können dich ganz schön in die Irre führen. Von daher war das so meine Anekdote des Tages. Mir fällt jetzt auch tatsächlich nichts mehr ein. Wenn mir noch etwas einfällt, musst du noch mal kurz vorbeikommen. Das gebe ich dir in einer Minute. Dann erzähle ich dir die kurze Anekdote. Aber ich darf mich auch sehr herzlich bedanken, dass du hier warst, dass du mich ausgewählt hast. Und ich hoffe natürlich auch, dass es dir insgesamt Spaß gemacht hat. Mir hat es sehr viel Spaß gemacht, auch auf der Ebene über Fußball zu diskutieren. Total cool.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr schön, auch nach dieser langen Zeit. Vielen Dank. Ich hoffe euch, liebe Hörer, hat es auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in den sozialen Netzwerken Twitter und Facebook. Ich werde natürlich auch das Zertifikat von Alex verlinken. Ihr findet auch den Link zum Institut für Fußballmanagement. Wenn euch das noch weiter interessiert, könnt ihr euch da schlau machen. Und in diesem Sinne danke ich euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr dieses Tribünengespräch gehört habt. Und wenn es euch gefallen hat, hört vielleicht auch mal in unser Format die Schlusskonferenz und in den Kurzpass. Es gibt drei Sendungen des Rasenfunk. Es lohnt sich da mal ein bisschen zu suchen. Alle Infos auf rasenfunk.de. Danke fürs Zuhören, macht's gut, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.